Hi, we're already in the collab.
Oh, I, you can't hear their voices right now.
But I will, I will, I will unmute them now.
And we're gonna join.
That was kind of nice.
Oh, what's it called?
It's a collab.
So you can see them too.
If you have no pupils, will I join you?
Are we joining?
Wait.
Oh, password.
Okay.
I join.
Perhaps.
Password.
What's the magic word, guys?
What if you don't have pupils?
What if none of us have pupils?
Yeah, we should all do it.
We should all do it.
Join Peek.
Whose username is Peek.
Peek.
Wow.
Oh.
You're huge.
Come on.
Whoops.
Let me just uh, oh my god Oh my god
Okay Wait, let's hide, let's hide, let's hide Okay, okay Oh shit Oh, someone's coming in Oh god Wait, do you have eyes?
Mimi?
Oh, you know...
Wait, wait.
Oh, that's part of it.
Oh, he doesn't...
He'll give context.
I'll give context for my chat.
This is what Mimi looked like when I first...
When we first tried the room...
On my...
On my screen.
This is... Wait, oh, it did better now.
Oh, good.
Yeah, you're good.
It's good.
Oh, yeah.
um hello can you do y'all see me on the screen no no i don't see myself either i hope that i hope i turn up oh who are you i don't know any southern monnie who is this who the hell is it are you the real monnie or what yeah this is my this is my true culture your true culture oh i see my apologies oh wait huh oh i'm a ghost oh wait oh you're here I saw you I saw you come out come out oh come back I'm sure we'll come out we exceeded something so I think someone's gonna come in why are we so beefy we're beefy it's not great beefy girls like how we're all shoved into the corner right now we could take out more space if we wanted wait do hmm UI of the game,
I think there's a bunch of stuff, like your inventory is here, and then there's like your health and stuff here, so maybe like the middle would be the best spot.
Nice and close, nice and close, yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
Where's Monty?
Monty, I have no idea.
I don't know where I went.
It shows that you went over here.
Yeah, you zoomed that way.
Yeah.
Come back.
What the?
Come back to us.
Come here.
Come back.
The Lord have mercy on us.
I'm struggling.
I can go.
Okay.
It's because she's tall.
Where the hell is the bagel?
We're going to leave it and then I'll come back.
Oh, okay.
This is real.
Oh, this just shows the VTuber scuff.
What's so new?
And it's all new.
There's no scuff.
No scuff.
No scuff at all.
We're perfectly fine.
Everything's in your head.
It's perfectly fine.
But Mimi still got eyes on my screen.
No.
She went this way again.
Oh, she went this way again.
Oh, I saw it.
I saw it.
Yeah, she went.
She went.
I'm back.
Why are you all the way this?
Okay, Mama, can you try something for me?
Uh-uh.
Can you grab yourself and start sliding left?
Yeah, just keep going.
It's a little...
She needs an eye patch.
It's a little gore, yeah.
Oh, Mama, it's in an eye still.
Everyone looks great for me, surprisingly.
I'm shocked.
You know what?
That might be good.
Chosen child.
God.
Here, let me take a picture for what I see.
Oh, yeah.
Cheese!
I'll be your eye.
Oh, so sweet!
Oh, whoa, wait, you can be the pupil.
Wait, that's kind of...
Yeah.
Don't worry about it.
Okay, there.
Ta-da!
Oh, yeah, everybody looks normal for you.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Oh, I don't know.
I feel bad.
That's okay.
Moni's looked better on my stream before.
She can look like this now.
It's okay.
We all have bad days.
Just one bad day.
It's kind of a look.
I think, yes.
I think I'm good now.
We cannot do this if it's too beefy.
It's, listen, my computer, I bought her about five years ago.
Have it cleaned her.
She's struggling a little bit, but, you know, country girls make this.
We still love her.
I don't think it's you.
It's all right.
Okay.
Okay, well, are we gonna hide over here then?
I just need this to be handled with the game too.
Oh yeah, the middle.
Okay.
The middle.
It looks like we're telling secrets.
Hey, Manny, join us in the corner.
Oh, oh, okay.
Was it y'all talking about me?
Telephone, telephone.
Men, tell me something.
I won't listen.
Uh...
Manny, you're kind of blocking the whole...
Your boobies are kind of in your way, Manny Bagel.
Huh?
Oh, oh, oh, oh my.
Okay, uh...
Okay, pass it down, pass it down.
Manny, are you ready, Manny?
Okay, good.
Yes, I'm sure ready.
Really?
No way.
Oh my god.
Don't say.
Holy shit.
Okay, I'm done.
I'm done.
Manny, you gotta come over here.
I'm...
Hold on.
she's struggling oh okay i see i see where okay okay am i good now yeah yeah i think this is good i'll pass it down to you ready uh-huh the mic peeking right
right right uh-huh oh is that it yep that's it all right tell the class okay now tell everyone what we were whispering to each other yeah basically they said Whoa,
she got it, she got it!
Classic telephone, pretty sure that's what...
Perfect.
Yeah.
Perfect though.
You missed a little part in my ear though.
Oh, what did I miss?
What did I miss?
All right, about it.
It was, yeah.
It was a small part.
I'm so stupid.
I'm so sorry.
No, no, no.
It's telephone.
It's hard.
I need to go back to school.
So our vocabulary for this language.
Quit everything and climb a mountain.
Yeah.
That's a wonderful idea.
Come to climb.
Climb.
Now is now a great time to tell you all, I've never once climbed anything in my life.
Never?
Not once?
I don't think so.
You've never climbed the charts in a video game.
What?
Go for it.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Hey, if you're inviting me over, let me just...
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Holy shit, I think I made it.
Oh, God, the wind is so strong.
How did this happen?
Wait, what happens if I knock the mountain?
Ah!
That's okay.
I've got...
I've got a...
A broom.
I think I've got a broom.
in the mint's face you bleeding a little bit honey you need some band-aids i think you climbed her a little bit too rough i'm gonna need a band-aid because i'd scraped my knee falling for you oh yeah insert the reservoirs oh my god hey listen i worked on me what can i say yeah that was pretty good it's pretty good yeah oh thank you shall we play the shall we play the game we should do introduction i think oh yeah yeah yeah okay starting from mint and then uh right i know my left and right right right uh right uh hello everybody i'm mint fairtoe i'm a ghost made retuber and um i'm on youtube thank you You too.
Whoa!
Amazing.
Next.
Okay.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Monty Bagel.
Hey, everybody.
I love bagels.
Yes, I do.
And also, I have a southern accent today for some reason.
But you should go check me out.
I'm the cutest little country gal you've ever met in your lifetime.
Thank you.
Hello, everybody.
I am also Monty Bagel.
Ye-ha!
I eat bagels for breakfast, but I'm also a bagel.
And I'm a moat.
And I'm green.
Wait, I didn't realize I was the money left out.
Oh, no, you have to introduce yourself, Nick.
You haven't gone yet.
It's your turn now.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, it's my turn.
Oh, my name's a money bagel.
And bagels are my specialty.
I can't get enough of that bagels.
Thank you.
well I have something to say to y'all identity theft is not a joke and this is you you're laughing amongst yourselves and I'm over here scared for my life because y'all are gonna take my social security number y'all are gonna apply for credit cards and I don't know what else you're gonna get up to with my name trying to say that that I like bagels how do you how do you even know I like bagels that's the real question it's in my name but yeah not what I think not like a family tradition like you were you're the creative mr bagel was your father and well that's true yeah we do we do we do have a bakery where we only bake bagels i don't even know if you bake bagels honestly i don't know how you make them we just kind of guess over here hope it works out well that was great introductions guys i love that we're all money bagel gangers this is great no i'm monie bagel wait no but i'm monie bagel what but but wait i thought wait if you are monie bagel and i'm monie bagel then who's that who's
piloting the bagel i'm i'm too busy eating bagels okay okay you know what y'all can i i i i put my stamp of approval on you know make do credit cards and my name and stuff that's fine actually it's fine it's all good it's all fine y'all are all money bagel we can commit tax fraud yes oh freak yeah i'm excited whoever survives the mountain whoever so wait whoever gets to the top gets to be the real money bagel okay deal deal whoever dies first gets to be mage mimi yes okay wait that's even better oh they're both amazing whoa wait it i'd be happy to be either of them is there in-game voice for this i don't remember okay i did both yes i won't lie to you i'm low-key stalling because it's updating oh that's okay well it's almost done is it really now don't you worry oh wait i'm We can be in the game.
We can real apologies.
Hello.
In the game.
Hello in the game.
Wait, I don't hear you.
Oh, you don't?
I've always wanted to know what it was like to be eaten by an imp.
Would you like to find out?
Oh, yes, please.
Eat her.
Once you get in the game, I'll do my job.
Wait, how do you emote again?
chat chat help me chat chat oh i found it i found it what is she gonna do what's her next move wait whip hey wait nene wait wait oh okay hold on try again whip whip nene hey whip watch me watch me watch me watch me whip Watch me, watch me.
That's amazing.
Okay, check this one out.
Check this one out.
Oh, there it is.
All right, here we go.
Get ready for the trick of your life.
Whoa!
Oh.
How do I...
Okay, I'm grabbing you.
Oh, I'm not.
Oh, oh.
Oh, wait, this is it.
Whip, whip.
The audio version of this is crazy.
Just want you to know.
Yeah, I'm just like, come to the mirror.
I'm really imagining this right now.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Watch me whip.
Whip.
Watch me.
Nene.
Now watch me.
Whip.
Watch me.
Nene.
I don't think the world has seen better VTuber dancers than us personally.
Wait, can you hear me in the game?
No.
You can't?
Uh-oh.
Can you invite me again?
I might have misclicked.
I'm real.
I don't worry, you Southern Bell.
I'll do anything for you, my sweet apple pie.
Amani, have you speaking in your normal voice once yet?
Yeah.
What do you mean my normal voice?
This is my normal voice.
I don't even know what it is.
I've never spoken differently.
i'm being hugged by apple pie oh moni does give pretty good hug say something oh ha can you guys hear each other in the game no but your mouth also isn't moving
interesting interesting moni looks a little scared you okay well what i'm you look like you're seeing i'm i'm i'm i'm just i'm i have i have anxiety about flan you know i'm scared Oh, don't you worry?
Oh, nothing bad can happen in a plane.
Right, right, right, yeah.
Unless I'm only piloting and I'm not really good at that.
Did you know that there are more likely to be car crashes than plane crashes?
So theoretically you are safer in a plane than you are in a car.
Thank you very much.
Yo, you just cured my anxiety.
Well, you guys invite me to the game, pretty please?
Yes, let me do that.
Thanks.
You're welcome.
Whoa, whoa, where are you putting your hands, lady?
No, I wasn't doing anything.
Guys, woohoo, woohoo.
I'm touching your badges.
You know, you got some cool badges.
Yeah, you got some cool badges there, Scout.
Oh, do I?
Yeah.
Do I?
I mean...
I think we should take some off of her.
Hey, hey, hey, wax your hand away from me.
Stop that.
I'm gonna get away from my badges.
I worked very hard to earn.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, whoa.
Wait!
I can hear you.
Oh, I hear you too.
Hey, princess.
How are you doing today, princess?
Can I help you get to the top?
Oh, yes.
I'm gonna help you get to the top, are you?
Oh, no one has ever told me that before.
Princess, can we get you to the top, princess?
I think we're all developing some type of weird character that we're doing.
Maybe this is, we needed the role play all along.
Maybe that's what this is.
It might just be.
Should we just mute ourselves in the game then?
That's what I was thinking.
Maybe we'll just...
I'll do push to talk.
It's okay.
Yippee!
Your character looks so cute.
Yeah, so ready for exploration and...
Yeah, look at that pose, that demeanor.
Everything about it.
Oh, thanks.
Thanks, princesses.
I'm so excited to go on this mountain with you.
Let me see.
I'm going to practice.
It looks kind of like we're trying to strangle each other.
Oh, I'm hanging.
Oh, oh, oops.
You look a little traumatized, princess.
I told you, I'm scared to fly.
Wait.
How do you...
I think this might be smart.
But I like the best smart idea.
Hold on, wait.
Oh, hey.
Suckers, I'm going the fast way up.
What?
You can make it!
Oh, God!
Oh.
All right, hold on.
I know.
I'm going to make it this time.
Come on, Dolly Parton.
You got this?
Jolene.
Dollyane.
Oh!
I did it.
Help me out.
How do I grab you?
Wait.
Hold on.
Just jump.
A leap of faith.
Oh.
All right.
That might have been my fault.
I'm so sorry.
Come on up here.
Ow!
Oh.
Safe.
So how does one climb something?
Oh.
You just click on it and climb, baby.
It's instinct.
Oh.
Oh, I'm seeing that.
Yeah.
It's instinct.
It'll take over you.
I fear we might be cooked.
No.
Nah.
Lion does not concern himself with falling.
I helped you out.
Thank you!
Oh my god.
How do you push people?
You can win?
Huh?
How do I push people?
Shut up.
Shuffle, shuff, shuff, shuff.
Oh no.
Shuff.
Goodbye, princess!
Please help me.
I'm...
Oh!
Grab my hand!
We're gonna figure this out.
We might figure this out.
Just jump!
Oh!
Yeah!
I think you did it all on your own.
I know.
I think I needed you.
No.
I needed you.
You got that climber spirit.
Oh, I just pushed you!
Oh, I pushed you!
No, no, no, no.
Oh, he's on me, really.
Dive.
Dive is a cold, sad, lonely death.
I think we're ready, team.
Yeah, I think so, too.
We could possibly go wrong.
Yeah.
We've been training for this for so long.
Oh, Miss Money.
I heard you're scared of planes.
I could maybe hold your hand while we're on the flight or something.
You want to hold my hand, Minto?
I'm also so scared.
Oh, I'm so scared.
Yeah, yeah.
I have two hands.
You're a little clammy right now.
Group hand holding.
Oh, my.
I like the colors.
Yeah.
We're like inverted Powerpuff Girls.
You all have very soft skin.
Oh.
I lotioned.
Start.
Are we doing B-fall difficulty regular?
Yeah.
That sounds good.
Alrighty.
Okay.
Here we go.
Launching.
So I got a BBL yesterday and they told me that my ass is too fat to fly.
I hope it doesn't cause any problems.
Oh, I'm sure it won't.
I'm sure we'll have a great flight.
In fact, that's a delight for us.
Thank you.
Yeah, of course.
Oh, God.
Whoa, what just happened?
Her BBL, it was her BBL.
Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry.
Man, you have way too fat of an ass.
This is unbelievable.
I told you.
I told you all!
I should have jumped first.
I'm sorry.
You know, we could have landed in the water.
You would have floated from your cheeks.
Oh, true.
Oh, play that thing, girl.
Play that thing, girl.
Oh!
Oh, you're so musical.
Yeah.
So musical.
She's really good.
Oh, yeah.
He's really good.
Who's a bing bong?
That's that guy.
You want bing bong?
I don't want bing bong.
Wait, whose backpack is this?
He looks like Duolingo.
Duolingo.
It does look like Duolingo.
I'm going to spend a lot.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Give me a beat.
Oh, okay, okay.
Ugh.
We crash because of mints.
BBL.
Where the hell are we?
We're gonna die.
The end.
Bang.
Song of the summer.
I'm coming.
I'm telling you guys.
We're gonna be a hit.
Oh yeah.
Stupid book!
Who reads anyways?
I could eat it maybe.
You think that would help?
You could try if you'd like to.
Don't watch.
It's embarrassing.
Oh, okay.
Let me look away.
You're right.
I'm so sorry.
Hey, watch where you...
Look at your face.
Hey, watch where you're going, dude.
I'm harassing me.
Did anyone else notice that Monty Bagel disappeared from the screen?
Yeah, we're having a few issues.
We're just having a few issues.
What do you see with those?
What do you see with those, huh?
You see anything special?
I see.
It's like...
It's...
Wow.
It's amazing.
She said no, chat.
She said no.
Because words can't describe.
Oh.
Yeah.
It's better.
Are you gonna use that rope and pull me in or something?
I'm gonna lasso your heart.
baby whoa whoa i'll parkoon your heart oh welcome back buddy oh oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah already i'm just kidding oh please we consider such something so bowed so bowed oh god wait this place looks crazy it's a mountain yeah i'm not gonna make it y'all i'm looking at that mountain in front of us i'm gonna die No,
no, no, you won't die.
You'll just fall and it'll hurt a lot.
No, you'll die before it even hurts, so...
Oh!
Yeah.
You seem to have experience with it.
There are many different ways to look at life.
Actually, I beat this game with...
Wait, really?
Assistance.
So you are the carrier with...
So you got carried?
Well, do.
Well...
Do.
Yeah.
Do...
Dull.
Yeah.
I have, I found the kids cuisine on, in that luggage right there.
It looks, it looks like it might have been sitting for a few years, but I figure if y'all are good, I can, I can give y'all a little bite.
Maybe one bite per day, per person.
You have any expired baloney?
Uh, yeah, it seems like I do got some in here, actually.
I like the, the, the, the, yeah, the pudding.
Yeah, me too.
I like it, too.
yeah there's a lot that i like about that yeah yeah oh my gosh i'm doing it i'm playing this game i'm climbing we're doing it guys we're climbing it no we're climbing right now you know i think we've got 100 survival rates you think so i'm gonna eat this and hopefully it doesn't kill me don't eat those don't eat those Eat it,
eat it.
She thinks fine.
Oh, she...
No, that's normal.
That's normal.
Oh, is it part of the process?
Yeah, yeah.
It's normal.
It was just a little poison.
No worries.
Please don't get poisoned, please.
Oh, yeah.
Grab my hand.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
I'm getting lethal company flashbacks from this.
I'm going to die.
No, you got this.
I got you.
Give me...
Oh.
Hey, don't worry about it.
It seems that two of the ducklings lack some feathers on their wings.
Oh, what did you just say?
I think.
Look at how she's looking at us.
You called me.
A featherless duck.
You heard me.
Over there.
I'm sorry.
You better run.
I think the poison's taken over.
Oh.
There she is.
Dude.
Come on, little purple gal!
Something about this game don't really like me!
The fog is coming!
The fog cometh!
The hole?
Who is coming?
The fog cometh.
You think I would probably... I should have probably done some research on how to play this game.
I'm coming, baby!
Oh, oh, good lord.
Oh, you were so close!
Saw your little purple head.
Go up the rocks individually.
Like, look, follow my ping.
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing.
Bing, bing, bing, pink, pink, pink, pink, pink, pink, pink.
Okay, if you want to try, we can try to pick you up from here.
Yeah, I got my hand outstretched ready.
And I'm holding your butt so you don't fall.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, you're getting real slow.
Yeah.
Come on.
Go!
By the way, when people are reaching their hands, out to you you have to look up at them and right click or like hold right click on them so the hand can connect oh really okay grab i mean i knew that so try one more time right or left uh right click and look at me oh i suppose your stamina is too low now oh my god do you need a snack kids cuisine yeah do you need a snack i have the granola bar okay oh okay you could climb the tree and get some coconut or you put the lamb in the coconut i'm gonna be slow now but once i get the hang of this it's gonna be cooked for everybody else you got it you got it yeah go up there okay what you're gonna do is you're gonna go up there before you jump before you do anything okay you're gonna you're gonna hold shift while you jump forward okay because you're sprinting and then when you're over here look up at me and hold right click on me okay okay go ahead give
I'm so sorry.
No, no, no, that's okay, that's okay.
Listen.
We were very close.
I'm nothing if not resilient.
I will tell you what.
Look at me.
Up at me.
Oh, come on.
You did it.
You did that.
Don't touch that.
Oh, my butt.
Come, come.
Oh, I can help you hold that if you want to hold that up.
the purple...careful the purple...
Oh, come come!
Oh, oh.
Oh, come, come!
Oh, come!
Oh, I got you.
Oh, yeah!
There we go.
Come, go.
Listen, listen.
I'll get the hang of it.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, you'll get it.
Which would be a good way to go.
Maybe over here.
Oh.
I was trying to scout a little bit.
Oh, yeah, this might be a better place.
So, sound.
The fog… I don't know if I heard that.
I got a boss.
You got a boss?
The fog is coming, the fog coming.
I'm scared.
Baby, I'm scared.
Don't be scared.
You have eyes to protect you.
You have like a fan or something that's dog-proof, perhaps.
A fan.
I have my breath.
I can go...
That might work.
Okay.
Give me your hand.
Nice.
It's working, it's working.
Oh yeah, Manny, really show that.
Nice.
All right, this is real dangerous.
Y 'all y'all see this slope right here?
Uh-huh.
I'm so scared.
It's about a 448 degree slope that's real difficult.
448 maybe.
I don't think the degrees don't go that high.
No, it goes that high.
I got a degree in that.
I got a degree in degrees.
She got a degree.
And degrees.
The fog!
Oh my.
I smell it.
He's cooking.
What is that?
Oh, did anyone get the backpack?
Whoopsie, I don't think anybody brought them.
I didn't get it that bad.
It's alright, we don't need it anyways.
We're too good at this game.
Oh, I got a chubby shroom.
I'm gonna eat it.
What happened to me?
Do you feel dizzy at all or anything?
No, actually, it's great.
Everybody eats the chubby shroom.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll trust you.
I'll trust you on that, maybe.
The fog is getting good.
If Mint tells me to do drugs, I'll do it.
It's nice.
It's natural, holistic.
so yeah it's it's a natural plant it's a natural plant yeah exactly i would never put you in danger oh good lord don't come up here oh why oh oh um this way yeah i there's uh oh wait we went past the bridge yeah you're right oh okay just kidding wait that's fine don't worry about me just a little just a little mishap okay you know i made it yeah it's okay wait there's a bush here of food in order to go up you need to fall down sometimes you know that's just life man that's life all right here we go oh miss bagel um i took a tumble what's the crisp berries were these poisonous try i'll try to make it this way if possible i need foods man there's foods here i'm coming to get the foods yeah there's a couple you can do it okay i'm coming Yellow,
red and yellow.
Kill a fellow.
But not this one.
It's good.
Yes.
Oh, you're so talented.
You're doing great, darling.
Thank you.
I think we're getting too far to the side of the map, though.
We got to go back a little bit.
I think.
We got to circle in this way.
Green is nice.
We got to start heading over there, maybe.
Oh, thanks.
All right.
Let's do do do do do do do.
Yeah.
I'll have a back.
is going fantastically so this might be a great time to ask have any of you guys got any wilderness experience um the silent wilderness experience i've glammed once you've glammed what is what no i have i lied i lied to be to fit in i'm sorry oh no it's okay i've never gone camping once in my life there's some food here too oh wait it's green though green is that i got a I got attacked by a bunch of ticks.
So, didn't do that again.
By ticks?
Omani, you got to see it again.
I'm coming back.
It's okay if it's too hard.
My computer being from 8,000 years ago, one of the first computer prototypes, I think.
Oh, you got one of them.
You got one of them microwaves, right?
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
I see.
of them before you've tinkled with one of them you tinkled a microwave i've tangled miss how inappropriate of you to say i would hope i've never kissed anyone oh no oh good lord oh good oh dear heavens me what shall we do our southern bell where's our sweet southern bell the stables Long country roll The stables of coffee hall To the place I belong Yo,
can I have some?
Yeah Oh, I thank you Just put it directly into my mouth.
I did.
Oh, I guess I consumed it really fast.
Are you able to rejoin or?
I don't think so.
I don't think I can rejoin.
to start from scratch yeah that's okay this was a practice run yeah you know what this means guys are you guys sure i can i can i can just watch a lot i can be like a commentator no absolutely not we're going here i go oh nice death has claimed me i believe i'm dead i could make it i could Make it.
Oh, just kidding.
Wait, actually, I lived.
Really?
Now I'm dead.
Good job, team.
That was great.
That was wonderful.
I loved it, Picasso.
That was good practice.
Good practice, yeah.
Wait, my chat's saying you could rejoin.
Oh.
Well, it's a little too late for that.
It's okay.
Well, well...
Uh...
YOLO.
Okay.
Let me...
Let me do a little funny and invite her again.
Hold on.
Okay.
Yeah, it might be better if y'all bring the worm in, if you know what I mean.
I'll bring the worm in, don't you worry.
It might be better to bring the worm in, yeah.
We can bring the worm in.
Who's the worm?
Oh, the worm!
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, I don't want anybody to be alarmed by my appearance, but sometimes I have to do this.
If you can't accept you at your worst, you know.
Yeah.
Something.
And worm money, worm money is so, so slimy, you know, I love her.
Yeah.
Guys, this is worm money.
Look at it.
I'm looking real nice today.
I did my makeup especially for this.
Oh, I wonder if I can rearrange these.
You know, I think...
No, this is great.
This is wonderful.
Worry not, folks.
Yeah, and the good thing about this is if we get hungry on that mountain, take a nibble on my little tail yeah it's pretty big i'm real i'm real packed with sustenance mommy i have to tell you something what i was thinking the raid that just came in and i did it entirely in a southern accent oh my i'm rubbing off on you you're you're spreading your southern bow i'm rubbing off on you oh thank you so very much so it's so easy to just they like lock into it you know yeah indeed yes it is all right are you guys ready for round two round two and now mimi has more experience so now she'll be able to do it and i know exactly how to do it and there's not oh oh i picked up a friend a friend this this flight will surely not will be fine did you did you remove your bbl or have has it still actually i went for Round two.
Oh, round two!
Oh, God.
B-B-B-B-B-L.
Big, big, big.
Whoa, oh, oh, whoa.
Are you, oh.
Uh, the flare is kind of going crazy, isn't it?
Let me see.
Whoa.
Oh, it's dancing.
Man, I'm going to be real honest with you.
I think your doctor might have scammed you, honey.
It's looking real flat today.
Flat!
I think you sat on it too much, honey.
Oh, God.
No, no.
Y 'all, we're gonna have to take her back.
Wait, let me see.
Let me look in the mirror.
Okay, well, actually this is the normal before it was concave.
So actually, oh, you know what?
That's an improvement, actually.
You can take a bite of my worm tail.
It's got a lot of protein, so it might help it grow too.
I'm a growing girl.
Is Mint a grown girl, yes or no?
Yes.
I'm not sure.
What?
Oh, bing bong isn't too sure about that.
Ask again, ask again.
No, you can't ask the same question.
The answer has been spoken.
It might be confused because you're short.
Yeah, yeah.
How tall are you?
Very, very tiny, very tiny, short.
Is she short?
Yeah, she's super tall.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's ask another question.
Somebody else, go ahead.
What am I going to eat for dinner?
Yeah.
Well, I got a question.
Okay, go ahead.
You can squeeze it.
Do the honor.
Do it fart.
If I say it.
Oh, yeah.
Squeezed it twice.
All right, we got this is the concise answer, Bing Bong.
Do it fart.
No.
I think you embarrassed him.
He said yeah at first.
Bing Bong, do you want to live?
I don't know how to squish him.
How do you squish him?
Uh, left corner.
Sure.
Oh, he does want to live.
He doesn't sound very sure about it.
Kill him!
Fire in the fire!
Oh shit, I killed myself too in doing that.
Jesus Christ.
Don't step in the fire.
Hey, don't step in the fire.
It's quite hot.
Oh, is it real?
The fire?
Oh, he's tweaking a little bit.
How do I use this?
what is she sniffing oh my god catch oh I'll get it next time that one I'm getting it alright here you go here you go yeah yeah you got me in the jugular it's okay it's okay I got this I got this one we do we do should we go out the mountain yeah yeah yeah probably probably oh you know that's great that's fine how tall are you again uh 160 centimeter oh what's that an american we're american oh what is that six feet american oh really no way oh i fully believe you yeah you should i would never lie to you guys You know,
wow.
I appreciate the honesty, honestly, I really do.
People are hungry.
Thank you.
Wait, there's some here too.
You're quite welcome, ladies.
I think there's a lot of short on short, friendly fire going on in between the two of you.
What are you talking about?
What?
No, we're both like eight feet tall.
You can't even talk about it.
Yeah, I've grown since this last conversation.
I think red is safe.
Yeah.
Guys, we all know Mani is the shortest here.
Of course.
Unless we're eight feet tall and Mani is one foot tall.
Wait, how do I use the backpack?
Because you're like a bagel bite.
Uh-huh.
Bagel bite.
Energy drink.
Where'd Minto go?
I'm here.
Sorry.
Hi.
I'm coming.
Snake is here.
He's right there.
Right there.
In the bush.
Wait, right here, this bush right here quickly!
Oh!
Wait, I'm out of stamina!
You found it!
Oh!
Oh no!
Silly legs.
Okay.
Uh, there's nothing there.
I suppose he went to the top already.
Gotta find him.
Gotta get down.
We gotta get there.
That's the goal.
That's he's there.
You two can become Charlotte Snake.
Snake.
We can become him?
Probably.
Oh.
No one can equate to that greatness.
I don't know if you want to do that.
Okay.
All right.
Upsi daisy.
I think we can just go the same way we went before.
Yeah, yeah.
Nothing will go wrong with that at all.
Hey, guys, there's some fruits down there if anyone's interested, but I don't know.
These rocks are treacherous.
Oh, nice jump.
I'm here.
Oh, I'm here.
Thank you.
To grab anybody by their hair.
Come, come, come.
Oh, thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh, I didn't even notice you pulling my hair like that.
Oh, thank you.
Pull in your hair, your luscious body.
Body?
Body!
Grab my phalanges.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, the phalanges.
All right, y'all.
Yes.
We're all speaking in southern now.
I've infected everybody.
It's true.
You did indeed.
Hold on.
My normal voice.
This is how I normally sound.
What?
No, no.
I don't know.
Y'all all said while we're Monty Bagel earlier.
I think it's just the first.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
I'm Monty Bagel.
What if I, what if we switch it up and we start talking in a different accent?
What?
Hello everyone.
Are we now British?
Oh, we're British now.
We're British now.
It's tea time, isn't it?
Which one of you has took a fucking share, forgot to forge the toilet.
Disgusting!
Hi, I'm Becky G and I'm gonna sing Share Lloyd by Share Lloyd.
By Share Lloyd.
Into the bee.
Where are we going?
Bum.
Whoa, I got a nice view right now.
That's crazy.
Where are you looking?
There were three of them right in front of me.
I couldn't help.
Um...
Oh.
Wait, there's some...
What?
That's so ominous.
I know, it's scary.
Oh no, baby!
Ow!
No!
Who wants some trail mix?
I got it.
I'm good.
I got you, baby.
You hungry?
Come in me, you hungry?
You know what I realized?
We've got a lot of M's going on.
For you.
Yeah, we do.
Okay.
I was just freaking out a little bit Don't freak out We're fine I'm freaking out a little bit I don't know You want the trail, Nick?
Okay, okay Someone taken it
Yeah, I'm gonna have some people's arses in my face all the time Wait, genuine question Have you guys all had a my little pony face?
um the silence is telling me no i liked it i did like it yeah i did like it everyone here gives me pony vibes i won't lie wait what pony do you think i like you're giving maybe like a flutter shy energy no no that's okay i'm flutter she's cool she's Oh,
oh, oh, no.
So who did you want?
Camilla's Pinkie Pie, no doubt.
No doubt at all.
Excuse me?
Pinkie Pie.
I think I have the perfect one for Mint.
Oh, yes.
Derpy.
Yeah.
No, that's Vivi with her eyes.
With the eyes.
the eyes that's fair hey listen i know when i'm beat oh wait help me help me i go ah why didn't you hold on i tried you'll want some more we're here yeah come here we're here we're here we're coming yeah come on take my hat oh thank you so much they don't love you like i love you wait
They don't love you like I love you.
There's some food.
I'm going to take it.
You know what pony you would be.
I don't know.
What do you think?
Applejack.
Thought it was obvious.
Well, it makes all the sense imaginable.
How do I put it in my bag?
I don't know.
I'm holding on to stuff, I don't know how to put it in my backpack.
Uh, you gotta place the backpack down, my darling.
What?
You gotta place the backpack down, darling.
Oh, I do?
Yes, you do.
Oh, no.
And you dropped it.
The apple.
Don't drop the backpack.
I don't think it's worth it.
Is there any more?
There's more.
Oh.
Good job.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I got one.
okay i'm coming good sorry no you're fine we're gonna we kind of got a hold of this if y'all haven't noticed we're kind of just like we're crazy yeah for those who are still in you for those who are still in the studio shift to the right a little bit okay oh okay i will once I'm done climbing.
Alrighty then.
I can't stop climbing though.
Oh.
There we go.
That's fine.
Oh.
More to the right, my dog.
Hold on.
It's telling me.
It hates me.
Yeah.
It keeps yelling at me too.
Okay.
To the right.
Yay.
Hopefully that's better for the, for you guys.
Yeah.
For the chatters.
Oh.
Oh, that looks spiky.
He looked quite scared of it.
Ew!
I'm not scared of nothing.
Watch.
I don't think we can go that way.
Can we?
Watch me.
There's nothing we can't do.
Yeah, yeah.
I believe you.
We've got to...
You can do it.
I mean...
I'm very...
I think I made it.
I made me.
I'm holding my hand up.
Don't make me die, darling.
Don't let me die.
Come on.
If it tells you to shift, do shift.
Shift!
Yeah, I am.
Thank you.
I think we're almost to the top.
I have no idea.
Yeah, me too.
I think so.
I think we made it practically.
In fact, we might be setting a world record right now.
You never know.
This game's easy.
Oh!
Yeah, totally, totally.
Which way should...
Oh, can we make that?
Oh, you guys can.
Okay.
I'm just following the crowd, if I'm honest.
I haven't made a single decision this whole run.
That's okay.
It's looking real good over here, I think.
Oh, whoa.
All right.
Oh, this is going down.
This is good.
I see a man-made structure.
A bridge of some sort.
A bridge.
Civilization.
I was hoping it was going to be like a cafe or something.
Oh, I have food if anyone needs some food.
Oh, it's okay.
It's a nightmare.
I'll save it for it.
I would like some.
You want some?
Yes.
Can you feed it to me?
Open wide.
Whoa.
I'm watching something so intimate.
You got a big mouth, little lady.
Yes, I do.
It's like Kirby.
It just sucks everything.
Yeah.
Oh, my.
Uh-oh.
Okay, I'm good.
Yes, maybe.
Oh, uh...
Oh, baby!
I got you!
We're fine!
Good job, everybody!
Yeah, we're killing it!
This is working out so spectacularly.
Spectacularly.
Spectacularly...
Spectacularly, giggly.
I'm following you, Mani.
I'm following you.
I'm going!
You got the...
Just... you got the way.
You know the way.
Oh!
I know the way.
Oh, I see!
trail mix nice trail mix huh yeah i made it onto this bridge why do you sound a little suspicious of my trail mix do you not believe me no i do i do okay well if you get hungry can't have any of the trail mix would you feel me yes i mean oh no did anybody die no bridge died we're finding
The campfire!
Oh my god!
Do you smell the burning wood?
You see that?
It's like a sleeper agent.
We buried it!
Yippee!
Big luggage.
Wait, are we like goaded or something?
I think so, actually.
Cookies?
Everybody get you a marshmallow.
Yeah, everybody gets a marshmallow.
A marshmallow.
Thick mints!
Oh, I got one of these already!
Yeah.
I got one of them.
My BBL.
With her double BBL.
Yeah.
Oh, tropics.
Oh.
Um, um, I want to feed this to somebody.
I don't...
Manny, do you want to feed each other?
Blushes a little bit.
Slicks my lips.
a little bit.
Okay, um...
You fed me the stick!
Does anyone need any more food?
I think there might be more food in this.
Wait, who wants to touch the ancient statue?
That sounds like it'll kill me.
Okay, I'll do it.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
I got a cure-all.
Okay.
What is that?
Is it cure-all?
It's the green juice.
Oh.
Yeah.
Guys, if you are still hungry, I do suggest eating the marshmallows As we'll never come back for them ever again Yeah Yeah Wait, did everyone's hunger get filled with it?
I forgot if that's how it works Oh, I don't know Oh, uh, let's put them in the backpacks then here Let's, uh, put them in here There you go, wait Drag it Can I have mine?
Oh, yeah I'm gonna take it Take it Wait, how do I take it?
Oh, there we go, okay I'm gonna eat it Cause I'm craving something a little sweet Ooh, the sweet tooth that's why I'm not gonna lie to you guys I have a confession to make yes I have purchased three entire containers of those tiny little cupcakes from Walmart little red velvet ones and I've eaten all of them in one sitting um I might as well have been oh you know what honey that's just fun yeah don't let anybody judge you for that and don't you let your say your doctor say anything no don't even tell your doctor don't even oh I won't yeah yeah yeah yeah but i i i you know what thanks you guys are so accepting that's nice i thought you guys were gonna be like wow that's too many cupcakes no no no never say that if it brings you joy then who cares thank you oh wow the rain listen my me mom told me never to judge
it's slippery it is slippery fuck it oh god she made it I did it okay oh no okay you want to hold my hand I'm going for it okay
I got a pink banana wait how do I get off of this thing wait get off the vine okay jump yeah we eat these yellow fruit No, don't eat the yellow ones.
They're suspicious.
Are they?
The red ones are good.
I'll try it just in case for you.
Oh, God.
They're so sweet.
Wait.
I'm okay.
You're okay.
Go right ahead.
Eat them all you like.
Eat them all you want.
Eat them up.
Reese's puff.
Peanut butter chocolate flavor.
Which way should we go?
I don't know.
We gotta get back up.
We went all the way down.
Alright, let's see this way.
These spiky trees look a little spiky, I won't lie.
You don't want to touch them.
Ow.
As I touched one.
Oof.
Does this look like a good way to go?
I can't tell.
Whatever.
Yeah!
That little square there looks real friendly.
Ugh.
Oh my god.
You like my sheer muscle?
Yeah, that was pretty impressive.
Oh, impressive.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yes, I'm just too good.
She can't stop winning.
Can't stop silly.
This is looking real frightening, y'all.
I don't know about this.
Oh, God.
Look at my spiky.
Oh, what are those?
What are those?
Whoa.
Oh, that's your hand.
Did you go to my ping?
Yeah, I was like, oh, what is that?
Oh, what is?
Okay, team, do we go A or B?
A or B?
B.
B for bagel.
Yeah, B for bagel.
B.
B, bagel.
Alrighty.
I'm climbing.
Don't mind the rain.
That's a little...
little slippery i was gonna say do we need to worry about that but i don't think so i'm sure it's fine it's probably fine oh thank you so much hi yo hi yo i got you thank you thank you kindly oh watch out for those flowers too they look pretty i won't touch it
oh oh maybe it's looking purple i love purple things oh
You guys are just basking in it.
We're basking in the funk.
I persevered.
I climbed through.
Hey, you still got a bottle of that Kirol, maybe?
I don't know what it does, but maybe this is a...
No, I'm gonna... We're gonna save it.
Oh, wait, how bad are you?
It'll go away.
Don't worry about it.
Alright, it'll go away.
You're right, you're right.
I ended up really high up.
I don't know where I am.
Wait, uh...
Oh, oh.
Ah!
Oh!
I don't think I can make it up there.
You can do it, you can do it.
You gotta wait for the poison to go down, darling.
Oh, does it auto go down?
It does.
You just have to wait for it a little bit.
Oh, that's nice.
Wait, I can offer a hand up here, perhaps.
Is this your own attack?
Let me wait for my poison to go down.
I like the thought, baby.
I'm gonna eat it.
Wait, I'm gonna give this to you.
Manny.
Take it.
Oh, God.
Jesus.
or not.
It might help you though.
Does it help?
Oh.
Oh, it hurts!
Sorry, I should have tested it!
My princess!
I should have tested it!
Wait, put the banana peel down?
I'll show you something funny.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
You're gonna have a whip I throw it at you.
Oh!
Oh God!
I'm sorry!
Oh!
Oh my god!
You know, this sounds really interesting when you don't know what's going on down there.
That's what I was thinking.
She slipped on my nanner.
Let me show you something funny.
I have.
She opened my nanner and slipped on it.
What?
That's true.
Is she, huh?
You are what?
Maybe we do use the cure-all.
Nanny!
Darling, I don't think that's very safe.
Let's head up there.
Let's head up there so they can get over here.
Okay, okay.
My poison that- oh, it's going down a little bit.
Why?
It's like very slow.
We're- yeah.
Okay, hold it.
We're holding.
We'll make it out of this.
I'm real scared.
You know, at the beginning I said I got anxiety and it's just really off the charts right now.
No, no, don't be scared.
Yeah, don't be scared.
Here, I'm gonna go.
Honestly, your BBO was worth it.
It's looking good from this angle, honey.
Is it?
I really hope so.
Yeah, it's looking real good.
It's not concave at all.
Oh no.
Oh no, if you guys didn't help, I can't come back down.
Let me come back down.
Let me mosey my way back down there so I can grab your hands.
We're struggling a little bit.
All right.
One more time and I'll grab your little fingers.
Bandage.
Come this way, I'll help you guys.
Oh.
Ah!
Why did that not work?
Okay, okay, okay, one of you.
One of you.
Hey, hey, one of you down there.
Okay.
What is that?
Oh.
I want to stay out of the way so there's room to climb up.
I got it.
Take it.
It'll help you climb up.
Okay, Manny, you want to try getting up here?
Yeah, yeah, I think I can do it.
Okay.
Do you guys need any food?
Reach your phalanges out.
I'm coming.
My phalanges are right here.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Make sure to grab them nice and tight and squeeze them.
I'm going to grab them real good.
I'll go.
Maybe if you eat, do you guys have food?
I've got food to give you if you need it.
I got this...
Alright, oops, sorry.
We're gonna use the cure all.
Do you need... We've got red berries up here, quite a few of them in fact.
If they cure all, they'll be fine.
I'm curing me.
I'm curing you.
Did that cure?
The fog is rising.
And we still got something.
left yeah okay let me feed you darling you guys i'm kind of worried no it's just a little thank you darling oh i did it this way oh you guys get it oh no okay i'll stay too well i can't i can't i reach it every time you can do it mid-tone let's go oh thank you baby all right yay okay all right Oh my god,
I thought you almost slipped.
No, we're okay.
We're okay.
You can do it.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's go.
It's the BBL.
You know, you didn't hurt yourself at all because it kept falling on your cushion.
Yeah.
I've never had that before.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
I have a surprise for you guys making it up here.
Malibu!
Wow!
Oh, please, please, can I have a lick?
Just a lick.
Lick the communal lollipop.
The communal lollipop.
Oh, oh, oh.
I think you had the whole entire thing.
You were hungry.
Oh, my.
Dude.
But, hold on.
Growing.
Growing, girl.
I can't see straight right now, dude.
Dude, stuff that lollipop was laced with something, dude.
No, you're like glowing right now.
You're like glowing.
It would never do anything like that.
It would never waste anything.
You're doing great, darling.
Oh.
I was about to say, look out!
Come, Pentee.
Make your way up here.
Oh, I like the color it makes.
It matches your hair, Camila.
I think we should stay down here for a moment, Pentee.
I'll have you know something.
Yeah.
I didn't step in something.
I farted.
She farted!
What?
Camila farted.
What the hell?
You farted.
Wait, where do we go from here?
Uh-oh.
I'm not quite sure.
There might have been a brief miscalculation.
No, no, no.
Let's try going this way a little more.
Aki.
Oh.
Just to see.
We didn't miscalculate anything.
This way, maybe?
I don't know.
Stinky.
What's that right there?
Are the bugle mushrooms saved or the budded mushrooms saved?
I don't think the ones with the spots are...
Yeah, the ones with the spots are bad news bears.
Yeah, bad news bears.
see oh god don't step in that just tank it just tank it's crazy i'm already halfway poisoned he's threatening to port again oh god it's a little slippery it's a little down here wow oh no oh no all right i gotta admit that one was me i'm sorry why'd you pour it on us i'm sorry it was a lollipop oh no no she's still blind it's that stew that makes you blind except it's a lollipop oh the blindness yeah i don't really know oh i was about to say oh i didn't think i oh i thought it was the plant oh i have those don't you worry my darling darling um listen i uh listen that's on me fellas that one's on guys guys what happens when your entire bar gets full of purple death.
I guess we'll find out.
You'll be fine.
I passed out.
Oh, buddy!
Oh, no.
What do we do?
The stench.
You'll come back, right?
I'm awake.
Oh, you're good.
You're awake.
Walk it off.
The stench was too much.
I'm sorry.
It's them cupcakes that I had earlier.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, I think I have enough cure-all for one more.
Monty Bagel might need it, I think.
Who?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
All right, Monty, coming out.
Thank you, sure.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, that's nice, yeah.
Yeah, that helped, that helped.
Yeah.
That took a little bit off, the little of the edge off, right?
Yeah, it took a little bit of the edge off.
I think it was like, oh, I was needed, okay.
Guys, something crazy just happened.
What?
Limeu is here.
Limeu?
Limealicious?
Hello.
She's so delicious.
She's delicious.
Oh, James, you want me a smooch?
Oops, I mean, what?
What?
Who said that?
What the hell, guys?
Someone hacked into our game, I think.
I don't know.
Whoa.
Where is Limeu?
Something.
she's in chat she's in chat she is the one she is so good at this game lymu's the most is she yeah she's the one that carried i mean help i mean really really is this true lymu is it true i fear it might be it is truest yeah uh i think where do we go in my opinion i think oh i jumped down oh okay here this way oh i see i see so what i'm thinking i don't know if you guys agree or disagree i think we go this way this way this way this way this way like that okay yeah whatever you just said yeah absolutely totally yep yep 100 i don't have any reason to disagree with that oh gorsh oh gorsh all right watch out for dumb spikies watch your pretty little toes you're not tootsies
how many times do you think people like stubbed their toes while rock climbing what a bit i would have said well maybe not
okay oh oh god wow we don't have bing bong i think you get an achievement if you bring bing bong right oh he was dead it'll be an achievement if we make it let's be honest yeah Wait, don't touch those.
Don't touch those.
Big stinkies.
What if I want to touch it?
Wait, what if I throw something at it?
Do what you won't?
Okay.
Wait, you avoided it.
I haven't farted yet, so I think I'm safe.
Yeah, yeah, totally, totally, totally.
Can ghosts even do that?
I don't think so.
No, no, no.
It's not possible.
Roy, Roy, Roy.
okay all right oh how that's pretty steep up there though wait we can go like this way instead that up to there the fog oh oh it helps fellas we might be dead no we won't no if you think like that it will surely happen you guys are doing a great great job i just wanted to let you all know.
Oh, thanks.
Yes.
Yeah.
I heard that affirmations help people a lot.
I'm finna firm.
You know what that works for me, I think.
Positive reinforcement.
Yeah.
Yes.
I really, actually I do best when I'm given a lollipop.
Oh, so much loot.
Oh, I'll make sure to give you.
Oh, watch out.
Watch out.
There's big stanks.
Oh, good number bar.
And a sports drink.
Oh, boy.
The fog is coming.
Yeah, we gotta keep moving.
What is that?
I got a balloon.
Oh, cute!
What's it for?
It's a balloon!
Oh!
You're so cute!
It's so cute!
We can't lose baby now.
Don't touch it.
Watch the spikes, watch the spikes.
Oh!
Don't pop it!
Oh no.
This is like when you take a baby to the grocery store.
Or grandma.
What?
Baby, grandma, same thing.
Huh.
We can maybe go like this there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that looks good.
Which way?
Oh, wait.
This way?
Oh, this way?
Up there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think so?
Like, like this way.
Which way?
What way?
This way?
Maybe.
Oh, that way?
Is that a way over there?
Well, there's like a, well, oh, there's some, there's some spicy plants here, but...
this way this way is okay oh hello oh wait is it okay maybe it's okay um it's okay for where you are at least uh uh okay i'm trapped um oh oh no oh yeah yeah i'm dread no no no totally totally totally not were you looking for me or something yeah i saw you over here all alone and i just wanted Oh,
well, I do appreciate you dearly.
Did it hurt when you were getting quite close to me?
Oh, wow.
Oh, you're touching me.
You're touching.
She's touching me.
Touching you.
Sweet Caroline.
Ba-ba-ba.
Do you guys watch the guy on TikTok that, like, imitates Hugh Jackman?
Yes.
Bread.
Bread, bread, bread.
Oh, no.
someone with more experience might be able to make that oh good oh goodness you got this oh okay I'm gonna try the side a little bit it might be controversial though might be controversial though no no no oh I kind of made it actually wait I want to eat this granola bar and then I'll be stronger that did not work bread bread bread proud oh please Please!
Oh, please!
Oh, I made it!
Okay.
Anybody.
Grab over my paw!
Oh, you went down.
Okay, I'm on the way.
Oh, my paw.
Wait, are we at?
Wait, I had you!
What happened?
Guys.
Yeah?
I'm not in a good...
I'm not in a good way right now.
What's wrong?
Oh, wait.
Don't die.
The way Mimi's going is pretty good, I think.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I did just almost fog my day.
Um, Manny, you good?
Um, yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, Manny, try one more time, okay?
I got you.
I'm gonna loop up my hand for you nice and...
Oh, it's difficult.
No, it's counterproductive.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, yeah!
When in doubt, when in doubt, we move it.
Wait, can we- we can keep going up, right here?
I think?
But probably.
Maybe?
Probably?
Maybe.
Hey, we haven't died yet.
Yeah, I think there's a bit of, like, an inside route up here.
It seems.
Maybe?
Well, I'm going to trust your mint stinks.
How about that?
I don't have- The mint stinks!
Okay, don't follow me.
Don't follow me.
Don't follow me!
Not following, not following, not following, not following.
Darling, yeah, right over there sounds like I'm struggling a little bit.
I'm stuck and I'm...
I fell completely to the bottom.
No!
Wait, I have a rope.
Can I use that?
You think a rope would work here?
Oh, yeah, maybe.
How do I... Where do I... How... How do I do that?
What are you here for?
Why'd you come down here?
Oh, I was muted.
My deepest apology.
Guys, come down here.
Come down here.
I have a better idea.
Okay.
Because this is a team.
If one of us falls, we all fall.
Vivi!
Let's see.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, come on.
Oh, I'm down.
Oh, I'm fucking down.
Oh, no.
I'm thinking I'm thinking I'll go retrieve the body Oh no That's okay I got it
I got it I got it I got a bandage in there I need I need a real bad bandage Do it Shoot it Can you Can you put that on me baby Um Blue fruit I wonder if I can grab it Engle's crazy So that didn't work The way I wanted it to work No But it's okay You know what it's everything is fine You know we learn to We learn to make mistakes And we learn to learn from them Does that make sense?
God that was so stupid I'm so stupid Wait no you're not There's the rope No, no, no, you're the smartest.
Oh, no!
You dead drop!
Oh, I passed out.
Oh, oh, oh, no.
Oh, oh, oh, I'm bad.
Um, help.
Maybe I have something in my bag.
Help me, help me, somebody, help me.
Kill her, oh, shaman.
Oh, God, I'm going down.
Oh, please.
Somebody.
Please heal her.
Thank you.
Oh my god, I can't believe that worked.
Did it work?
I'll go back over this way and get my bandit.
How damaged are you, Mimi?
Very.
Uh oh, the fog is like pretty...
I know it's a first day kit.
Oh, wait, wait.
Did we pick up the bandit over here?
I used it on you, honey.
Oh, okay.
Right.
Oh, thank you.
helped a lot.
I don't need it anymore.
I do need food maybe though.
That might be a help.
Is anyone injured?
Not anymore.
Thanks to me.
I'm gonna end just a little bit, but I don't need it.
It's okay.
Maybe we can climb... Wait, maybe we can climb this guy.
Here, watch out.
Watch out.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, uh, you're gonna have to tank some of this though.
Wait, there's some fruit over here too.
Hunggy people.
Yippee!
It's red.
Red should be good.
Give to me the yummy fruits and things.
And we have trail mix and a bandage!
Let's go!
Alright, who wants to trigger the fart cloud?
I don't think we need to trigger it, did we?
We might be able to wait our way through.
What if I go like this?
Oh, we can just go around it here.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la.
Oh, how did he oh no.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Banners with me to the bottom.
Help!
I
watched you drop.
Hey, I'm not dead though.
I'm actually, I'm just, I'm just out.
Is everybody out or dead or how we doing, do you?
If you guys can get somewhere, go on by all means.
Yeah, yeah, for real.
Hey there.
You look good.
You guys look so silly.
Oh, you're not doing so hot.
Come, baby, get us to the drop.
I'm not doing too well at all.
Yeah, you're not doing so hot here.
So as we were falling down, I found a vine and I grabbed onto it as we were falling down.
Wait, actually, if you feed me, wait, if you feed me a banana, I'll live.
Where are you?
Oh, you're right where you were.
Yeah, she was right.
No, it's too late now, I think.
Yeah, it's too, oh, it's gone.
all right hey all right don't worry guys the simp will carry us to victory i think yeah the difficulty jump and this is kind of crazy i'm gonna eat that don't worry okay yeah what i've learned is that i'm sick yeah it's like right over yeah you are there it's like right so close you've got this A portable stove.
A stove.
Stove.
Watch your arm.
This is gonna help me a lot, I'm sure of it.
Commander, what's it like to be a ghost twice?
Are you a ghost squared right now?
Ghost squared.
This is just me in my...
This is me after stream.
This is how I look.
Huh.
Nice.
Guys, I'm not too positive how to get up there.
Um...
Who are you?
Use your...
I'm an M!
Camila!
Yeah!
Camila, you're right!
Yeah,
yeah, you got this.
No one's ever had this more than you have it right now.
You have it!
The most.
You're so...
Climb, beach.
Climb.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
We didn't come all this way.
We didn't die just for you to give up, Camila.
Yeah!
You understand me?
You're right!
You are so very right.
tail and keep going yeah i'm thinking which is the best way okay okay okay whatever way you decide is the right one yeah follow your heart i'm following my fart you're following my that there's a couple a little bit too much of that baby maybe we stay away from those ow ow ow all right Bananas,
any bananas here maybe?
Any nainais?
Some nainais?
There's some down below you.
I like to eat.
Eat.
Apples and bananas.
I like to eat.
Eat.
Apples and bananas.
I like to eat.
Eat.
No, that's a horrible route.
So what I'm thinking, this might be a little hard, and I'm little long like me but we're going to go the chest route i saw a bunch of chests over there oh yeah okay okay give me a moment yeah yeah i see the vision i see the vision but oh my gosh i've taken so much damage jesus what did you mean by your hard and long what did you i don't get it what don't worry you explain that a little bit further i don't get it no no no you don't want to know darling it's not pg-13s okay okay oh watch your farts okay oh i see the the fog but don't worry about it i'm not even gonna talk about it either no don't worry about it the fog doesn't exist it's all in your imagination oh oh god how did you i don't know how you did that you're a pro gamer
Oh my gosh.
Pro game.
Oh!
No!
Oh, wait!
How do I live every time?
I'm so beefy.
The beef.
Okay.
One more.
Oh, no.
Just one more.
The cold.
The cold cometh.
No, no, no, no.
No, no.
What will it take for me to die?
Whip and Nene.
Yeah, Whip and Nene's for us.
I have to pee very badly.
It will be right back.
Oh, go ahead, go ahead.
Listen, nothing could have possibly gone better.
That was truly, I think, the best.
Yeah, it was really good.
I think it's kind of rude.
I think it's kind of rude that Camilla didn't take us with her to pee.
but it's okay.
I just like thought after everything we've been through today that we would be like close enough.
Oh, so true.
So true.
Yeah.
We should really confront her when she gets... Yeah.
No, actually we should go meet her there.
We should.
Yeah, we should.
I mean, I could go pee right now.
I'll take you guys.
Oh, okay.
Hey, if you're offering.
Okay.
Well, let me get on discord on my phone oh oh this all right oh i wasn't prepared to see it all the way through i don't know if i'm i was into the bathroom jinkle jinkle
this is my my theory that vtubers always end up talking about p and i'm the one that started it this time this is oh you started every time i feel like well actually i don't technically Camilla said she had to pee, so...
That's true.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it wasn't me with her.
It's the pink one's fault.
Yeah, yeah.
Always.
It's why we're dead now.
For sure, yes.
No, that's not because I decided to jump off of a vine if I've heard of you to go up to the ground.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No.
I think...
Did we all fall from that vine except for Camilla?
I think so, yeah.
You know, maybe it wasn't...
the smartest idea for all us to all just take that blindly but that just shows we're so close because we trusted each other yeah and look like god yeah we trusted each other so much we were like we're the best sister friends if one goes we all go except camilla because she exactly and friends die together yeah yeah if you jump off a bridge well i'm gonna catch you first but but if you fall i'm falling too you know yeah if someone said would you jump off a bridge for that person if they told you to i'd say hell yeah well yes i would in fact you're telling me mony camilla and minter at the bottom of this bridge i'm jumping i'm jumping back at the port oh why are we all Oh,
this is so intimate.
Small little elevator.
Oh, I took her passport.
Oh, no, I didn't.
Oh, you're stealing her identity in real time.
Yep.
Huh.
Yeah, give me that.
Give me that.
Give me your lunch money, too.
Excuse me, pissed princess.
Excuse me.
Tuition chest.
Yay.
Yeah, I'm cabodoning right now.
Oh, are we like... Oh, yeah!
She's being like double cabodon.
Yeah.
Wait, you cabodon her.
I'm gonna cabodon you at the same time.
Hey, princess.
Hey, princess and princess.
What the heck is going on in there?
Come here.
Come here, princess.
Okay, I'm gonna mute this.
Hey, princess.
What's going on, princess?
You have a bunch who owned it by two 160 centimeter gremlins before point size?
What is 162?
I don't know.
I just assumed because that should have been said earlier.
Yeah, actually, I'm 170 now.
Oh, shit.
Right, right.
I'm 5-1 in freedom units.
Is that similar?
Yes.
Right, right, right, right.
How'd you do that?
Wait, what's the...
It's R.
R.
A?
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh, did you just live?
What's happening in here?
Hey!
What are you guys up to?
Hey, Puente.
Oh, no.
You were gonna climb around with me today?
Oh, man.
Oh, no.
Wait, I'm gonna ride it all the way to town.
they see me rolling they hated
patrolling riding dirty trying to get me riding dirty before we get on this plane i need y'all to listen to me i need y'all look at look into my eyes and i need y'all to behave sir yes sir the last two times we've been on a plane yeah i'm not gonna name names i'm really not because i'm i'm i'm fair but someone here has gotten multiple bbls and every time we have boarded this damn plane it has crashed because the bbl is creating its own oh gravitational sphere oh god i don't name names but they're green um oh so you're a greener you're like a shade of green you're a greenish now okay yeah you're a shade of green yeah
How could I be judgmental for someone being green?
If I'm also green.
What are you talking about, darling?
The green against green crime.
What's that new accent you've brought out?
Alrighty guys, well...
Be nice.
We're friends.
We're all in this crash together.
It doesn't matter who started it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Totally.
I take it.
How really?
Yeah.
Oh my god, you have so many balloons!
Whoa, we have so many balloons!
Yeah, I needed them.
You know, it was getting stressful climbing these mountains, you know?
Yeah, yeah, totally.
It helps me relax.
How not to die?
Wait, there's an actual book.
Never abandon a friend in need.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's just how to play this game.
Which we don't need because we're better than that.
Wait, there's actually...
You can like...
Wait, you can like crouch and people get on your feet.
shoulders and then you can jump to give them a boost yeah oh whoa you knew that wait that's kind of nice excuse me darling i've got you a question i've got a question for you it reminds me of you here you can take that darling yeah just oh my fucking face oh no oh fuck my knee oh no what's happening oh no oh what's going on what's going on here i need to get my
Just spit.
I have a lot of anger in my soul.
I need to get it out.
No, no, no.
You want to go next.
You can't catch me.
No, no, no.
Calm down, Quintex.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, right.
The jugular.
Oh, she caught it.
Oh, God.
I got it.
You better run, darling.
You better run.
Serpentine and world are scary.
Oh, shit.
Hello.
Oh god, no, she's got it again.
Everyone run.
Now I'm gonna do nothing with it.
I just want to keep it for purposes later.
Sure fine, darling.
Sure fine.
I bet I dare you to touch this thing, Camila.
This.
Eh?
Touch it.
What the heck is that?
And why should I?
Touch it.
I'll have her do it.
Hey, you should touch it, Mimi.
Touch it, Mimi.
Get closer, nice and close.
Yeah.
Ah!
Clumsy!
Oh!
Butterfingers over here!
Hit her while she's down!
I'm gonna get you for that one, Miss Blago!
Ah!
I got some rope.
That's okay.
No matter what, I still have Bing Bong.
Bing Bong.
Bing Bong will always save us.
How do we know how to get through this one, but we don't I don't know how to get to the next one.
Maybe the next one we should just go like a totally different route.
I feel like our route was kind of like a little iffy from the beginning.
No, no, no.
There's nothing wrong with any of the decisions that we made.
Never doubt yourself.
Um.
I've never doubt yourself, princess.
Pointers.
Is that thing gonna get old?
Oh no, I don't even know how you guys are doing that, princess.
It's like mine doesn't sound right.
I can't do it.
Thank you.
I wish you'd thank you for the ring.
Cove your poinsettias.
All right.
Your next poinsettias.
Okay, poinsettias.
The big jump.
The big leap.
Yes.
Oh my gosh, this is great.
That turned out flawlessly and amazing.
is mean no green is green is don't eat the buttons my beloved bad bad those are both bad bad news bears right there bad news button bears yeah
coconut coconut okay oh they're heavy coconut coconut coconut coconut you down there oh where I don't know, somewhere.
Behold!
Are you role-playing over there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Toilet.
Totally, totally, don't worry about it.
Don't even worry about it, princess.
Don't even worry about it.
Okay.
Like, I'm a goat.
I'm a wall walking.
Wait, you can walk on 90-degree walls like a goat.
Yeah, that's why they call me the goat.
Oh, that makes so much sense.
I'd be wall walking.
I'm doing, I'm making bad decisions right now.
I just want everyone to know.
I believe in you.
I don't know where I am.
I don't think it's where I need to be.
Oh, was that what was in there, the trumpet?
giving up my passion because i wasn't very good at it don't say that no you're a musical genius it sounded like no it sounded great is what it sounded like it sounded like boots from the toot no no you gotta you gotta believe in yourself believe wait where are we where'd it come here to go i don't know oh I see her.
Is she alive?
Yeah.
Or I could kill her.
And then...
Oh, this is not the way.
Don't follow me.
Oh, great.
I've made bad decisions, princesses.
Are you okay?
Are we all good?
I don't know where I am, actually.
We've climbed this twice now.
We might have.
I think...
I think y'all are on the right path over there.
We are?
Yeah.
I don't...
I think I...
Well, maybe...
Well, shit.
I don't know.
I think so.
Wait.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, thanks, Camilla.
Oh.
Were we not, darling?
I figured it out.
You found it?
Man, I think with every flight we're having, like, the air pressure is decreasing.
I mean, that's...
it's getting concave i hate to tell you no you know they get a little concave again they said that might happen they were like just don't they were like don't take too many flights especially if they crash they warned you and you didn't listen i didn't oh but we now we gotta go back oh yeah that's what actually what this trip is for this is what i went through to get the first you know what here i got this we can probably put that in there oh yeah like one that'll be one cheek fill that up that's what they mean with like an apple bottom you know apple bottom yes exactly and it's only in one cheek so we'll figure out the other cheek maybe we can put the frisbee in the other one yeah i don't think anybody would mind if it's a little lopsided might be a little asymmetry is beauty it's a new trend of asymmetry is beauty yeah yes like boobies putting put in Yep.
Oh, like the bunny challenge, the...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
The chubby bunny.
Chubby bunny.
But with apples.
Um, guys, I think it's over for me.
What?
Where are you, baby?
I don't know.
I've been so locked in, I didn't even realize.
No, no, it's okay.
Can you see my hand?
Uh...
No.
Oh.
I see...
I see my only hope is a suspicious green fruit that I will be eating in the nicest way possible you should probably jump off a cliff yeah you can kill and die and then we'll bring you back okay that sounds great actually um I am I am passed out on the floor oh you actually are die Mimi is cute oh no no no it's okay don't worry about me princesses i'm perfectly fine hello okay don't worry don't worry hey listen i will spectate you and oh hello oh my thank you oh you're a ghost did you have any good loot i had bon uh bing bing bong bong okay i think he's a curse i'm not gonna lie oh that would explain a lot wouldn't it
I don't know if I'm going the roadway, but I know I'm going.
I'll have a will and a way.
So there is a way.
Yeah.
You can do it.
I believe in you with all of my believingness.
Oh, okay.
Ooh.
What's this?
Explorers luggage.
I can get...
What's a scout cannon?
What the heck is this?
Oh.
You could shoot someone out of a cannon.
I grabbed it.
Wait, can I actually?
Wait, can I shoot myself out of the cannon?
What is that?
Okay, I'm going to try and get to the top with the cannon.
Oh, God.
Okay.
I've got a great view if it goes wrong.
Oh, I place it the wrong direction.
Oh, no.
That'll send you careening off the side of the cliff, I fear.
Oh, I accidentally put it the wrong way.
you should use it still okay see what happens it might be yeah all right light it up light it up bye-bye have a nice time oh have a nice fall see you next spring
there goes my baby you broke most of your bones i think i i also landed in poison so i just still like mega died that's not really helping you i feel like i'm near in the top here oh no my darn are you really sugar plum oh no oh hey that's okay listen that happens sometimes yeah yeah yeah i knew it was gonna happen we're gonna get y'all back don't worry yeah we're gonna do our very best to bring you back from the dead yeah it's okay you know you know mince she's quite used to being a ghost so i'm sure he's not that I did it for science.
For science.
It beckons.
Where is Camilla?
I'm over here.
I honestly have a lot of faith that Camilla can make it.
Yeah, I do too.
Oh yeah, it's easy peasy.
I think you have to touch the statue to bring us to life.
Oh, dokey dokey.
That statue, I'm gonna touch it.
You're gonna rub all over it?
Yeah.
Oh, Jesus.
I'm a little cursed.
but that's okay and hungry you want to be cursed with me yeah little curse buddies curse buddies oh my god uh wait where's the camp oh up here oh right over here oh i would like me like a little fresh melon now me me here go honey i'm gonna attach this balloon to you so we can find you yeah yes hi thanks it's a little waypoint now it's not is not meant to be condescending i'm just i won't you know you have to find you let me kiss your ball head come here oh it's cute it matches your clothes very nice oh thank you whoa i i really do appreciate it did everybody get a marshmallow yeah sorry already i eat in my miller guys how where do we go all right this is the issue so let's let's look at it from on top of this hill What we can scout.
Yeah.
I wish I brought my binoculars.
Yeah, that'd be nice.
Well, I can't decipher nothing.
Me thinks the opposite of what we did last time.
Yeah?
That sounds good.
Yeah.
Don't.
What if we go, like, straight through this clearing and just straight up the rock all the way to the top?
What?
Wait, what?
I just need to say something to y'all.
Before we go on to this adventure, I just noticed everybody's doing this southern accent.
Now, listen, I welcome it.
Come on.
But.
I need.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Are you okay?
I'm just fine, darling.
Now, I just need...
I got to ask y'all a question.
I want you to be real honest.
Yeah.
What do you call...
And Mimi, you know the answer.
You're not allowed to answer.
Oh, okay.
What do you call the things in shopping carts that you move your groceries around?
Shopping car?!
In gross case.
Yeah, what do you call that?
What do you call the shopping cart?
Yeah, yeah, what do you call it?
A buggy.
No!
How did I do that?
How did you know that?
That is insider knowledge.
No, that's Monty Bigel you're talking to.
Of course Monty Bigel we know that it's called a buggy.
Oh yeah, it's called a buggy.
Of course Monty Bigel we know that.
B-G.
You know how much I got clowned on that after I moved out of like the deep south and I said buggy and people were like what the heck?
What the hell is a buggy, darling?
No way!
What the heck is a buggy?
Is that a southern thing?
The buggy?
Yeah.
What is a buggy?
It's a shopping cart.
Oh, so it is a shop.
Oh, I just need to wait to answer a little bit.
Oh.
The buggy, the buggy, the buggy.
The buggy.
Jump!
I'm going through this hole.
I'm gonna follow you through the hole.
Yeah, it's pretty exciting.
Wait, there's a little pathway.
You don't even have to like...
You don't even have to work.
You found the secret pathway.
Yeah.
Down.
What if there was like a little thing here that said teleport to the top?
I don't know if we can...
get, I don't know if there's any ledges on the other side.
We can try the banana vine a second time, that'll definitely work.
Oh, oh, no, no, no, no.
Over here, there's, well, I don't know.
Pull on you, look.
Yeah, yeah, come over here.
Okay, look.
There's a vine up there.
Yeah, we're at the top.
Oh, I'm seeing what you are saying.
Point.
Use your fingers.
I don't know how to point.
Use your middle mouse button muscle towards that muscle.
You see that?
This one?
Okay, okay.
Oh, yeah, I see it.
I see it.
Well, now, hold on.
Now, where do we go once we get up there?
We keep going up.
Just keep going up.
Just don't question it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to grab it.
I'm going.
Come on.
I don't know if we're going to do it.
Come here, baby.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you, my darling.
You're so kind of me.
I think I'm going to watch first.
Yeah, maybe.
I'm going to jump.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh, I thought you were going to fall straight to the floor.
I made it!
Wait, you guys call it the floor or the ground?
Um, both.
Oh.
I guess that's good.
I got a road cam.
I call it my platform, my stepping platform.
My stepping platform.
Oh, this area might be kind of difficult.
Nah.
There's another vine here that leads kind of downward.
Wait, there's an ins- we can go in, maybe.
there's like this little walk oh yeah I like me oh sounds good oh my god you got you're probably gonna have to help her oh I got you oh she did it she did it yes you go the bugs oh okay let me know if you guys see how do I do I okay I'll scout okay there's bark flowers careful careful careful and does it look like there's a way up over there perhaps perhaps
kind of i don't know hey i'd try it
i don't think there's i mean we could try to get you see these clips over here we could try to get to those i don't know if we can make that what about that thing right down there though what if we go down first and oh
girl i'm gonna try it i don't know i have a better idea yeah okay i think think yeah hold on this should kind of work it's not a great idea i lied to you all okay oh oh oh goodbye everyone i'll remember you all therapy where'd you go where'd you fall i tried i don't go that way hey don't go that way eki listen so hard i do have a rope cannon i can shoot to somewhere,
but if we need an extra little boost.
I see.
Don't take risks.
I'm all about taking risks.
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Okay.
We've got actually worked out.
Oh, we're just doing it.
Okay.
Coming well.
Let's go.
What the hell?
But that's kind of going back to...
Well, I guess we have to go that way, huh?
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, what did you guys jump on to?
Oh, this one.
Do a flip!
Oh, there's a vine.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then there's a tree you can jump on to or something.
Then how should you get up there?
Okay.
Um, does anyone have a band-aid, maybe?
I have...
No.
Um...
Oh, Mint, I have a present for you.
For me?
Yes.
Oh, you got that out of it.
come here you're gonna love it oh my god oh mama come lick this lollipop oh i'm not gonna feel anything suspicious okay okay thank you you're welcome yeah i'm pretty sure you're putting something in the lollipop i just can't prove it yet i am seeing colors i'm seeing whoa oh my god whoa there's no way whoa whoa whoa oh my god so we do have a cannon oh we have another cannon i think we could use it to our advantage somehow yeah i think so too oh we should we should honestly just keep going with the suitcases they could help a lot yeah oh watch out watch out here yeah band-aid please oh i've got it i think we were here but i think didn't mean me die right here i think i got on the other side of the mountain i won't lie like oh earlier yeah and the first time we came through here oh yeah maybe that i think you died right there yeah i believe it maybe say hi to my old death spot for me yeah i recognize those bees uh-uh y'all watch out there the the random map
This ain't so good.
It screwed us.
Yeah, this ain't so good.
I'm sure it's fine.
All you need to do is...
Maybe we go try the other side.
Yeah!
Wait, does it randomly generate it every time?
No, it's like randomly generated every couple of hours or something.
Oh.
Something like that.
Yeah, so you use the same...
What about that?
What about this and that?
What's this and that?
Look for him pointing?
Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah!
maybe there's a lot of see before we go over there before we go over there i was looking at that or i was looking at getting on this tree and taking the vine here you see this oh uh-huh oh yeah yeah but which way do you guys think is better i think the tree might be better i think so too I think the tree.
Oh, oh, fuck.
No, I think it's already, guys.
I think the tree didn't want it.
I farted.
That tree there?
You've been putting down the trail mix, honey.
Oh, my God.
But I love the seeds.
They keep giving me good fiber.
Fiber.
Fiber, wipe.
Okay.
Watch out here.
If you're following me, there you go.
Whoa.
Watch it.
I'm watching you, mister.
Pop it a little.
Snip it a little.
Don't sniff it at all.
Don't sniff it.
Don't do that.
Jessica, you're going to get poisoned if you sniff it.
I won't lie to you.
Okay.
I'm here for a helping hand.
Come here.
Come here, friends.
Friends.
Are we here?
Wait, where's the rope?
Where's the tree?
Oh, is this it?
This is the tree right here?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, so we gotta go up a little bit more.
This one?
Yep.
The tree with the two tufts.
You know, these kind of look like Lorax trees.
They do!
Let it die!
Let it grow!
Oh, let it die!
There are two mindsets.
Alright.
Here we go!
Let it grow and let it die.
oh well i know which mindset i'm on i'm are you okay what's happening i don't know i don't i was stuck oh that wasted a lot of my stamina though no no no you can make it you can make it yeah i believe in you yeah i'm gonna wait for some of the fart poison to go away what just happened oh i see you're right okay let me reset it does let a lot of stamina Oh no!
Oh no!
Okay.
Well, where are you?
Oh this is me body!
Oh my god!
The world?
What the world?
Oh, I'm dead.
Why can you not go up there?
That's so dumb.
Oh god.
Oh no.
It's cooked.
we're so cooked we're cooked you got this miss bagel but we're cooked oh my god oh wow wowies oh you could do it you could do it wow a nice balancing game going on okay yeah yeah oh yeah you see me so yeah i do i just gave up so i can watch her you're just in this little crevice Oh,
gosh.
You look so lonely in here.
Yeah, I look.
Oh, boy.
I look kind of excited to be here.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I got somewhere.
Oh, my gosh, Monty is all of you.
It's all of you.
I know.
And if Monty wins, we all win because we're all Monty.
Yeah.
Because we're all Monty big.
I need some hype.
Tell me who I am.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go mommy bagel, let's go!
Let's go mommy!
Everything's seasoning!
Oh!
Cream cheese on the bagel.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, what did you say that one time?
Cover the crack, spread the cheese!
Uh-oh, watch her.
What am I slamming this guy's head?
No, no, you got it.
Money.
Okay.
Good job.
Just rest up.
Rest up.
Stunning, stunning.
Stunning.
You've got the best performance I've ever seen.
Oh, this is a little...
No, no, you're fine.
Oh.
Oh, how'd you do that?
Wait.
Have some of your trail mix.
Yeah.
Have your trail mix.
Take a good little.
There you go.
I have more stamina.
All right.
Nice night.
oh yeah climb that thing cool yeah show that mountain who is the boss of you are conquering yeah i would go to the right in front of you like the one i don't know what do you do with the frisbee i'm setting it throw it i'm so you can get more stamina yeah i'm letting go my inhibitions This,
this, this risby represents my inhibitions and my, my anxieties and mint BBL.
Oh, let it go.
Let it go.
No.
And just like that.
That was so beautiful.
I feel, I feel a hundred pounds lighter.
Wow.
Dang it.
What's that?
Dang.
Holy moly.
They were packing.
Yeah.
Why do you think we crashed?
What you keeping in there, darling?
Apples, apparently.
I will bring us to victory.
Yeah, you will.
You're doing fantastic.
Wait, how is your stamina going down?
Oh, because you're running.
Oh, okay.
Hey, hey, listen, you don't need to rush.
We will wait.
Except when the fog comes.
Oh, yeah.
You do need to rush away from that gift.
Now, can I climb this tree?
We will climb forever, though.
So don't worry.
your heart desires.
I mean, I don't know.
I think it's slippery right now, though, so it's a little tough.
Yeah, that might not be...
Oh.
That might be a little...
Yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Girthy, maybe.
All right, let's really take a gander at this.
Oh, there's a little rope over there.
Maybe I'll take that.
Yeah!
Yeah.
Well, if I can reach it.
If you climb up...
Yeah, you can.
You can go up there.
Oh, for sure.
Yeah.
That's easy peasy.
That's beginner climbers stuff.
For a moth like you.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Grab it.
Grab it with your thumbs.
Oh!
Nice.
Save.
Okay.
I'm thinking I'll take this and go up this way maybe or I can take...
Don't go too far to the right because you'll go into the fog.
Oh.
Yeah.
Maybe I take this to there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that looks good.
You can go to go to there.
Or maybe this one right here to go to there.
I think this one might be safer because stamina.
It's getting quite foggy, you do what you gotta do now.
I would also jump so you get more distance.
Grab!
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, that's gaming.
That's Manny gaming.
Manny gaming, baby.
That's our bagel.
That's our bagel, guys.
Yeah!
that cheese oh yeah turn around turn around to the left to the left yeah yeah oh big find it's like i can still hear her everything reminds me of her everything reminds me of the thick mints we cast aside my baby oh we're past that phase watch out watch out for the stinks oh gosh there's so many things don't stink up the place darling don't stink up you're almost there money you're almost there i can i can taste the victory yeah you can do it's easy what does it taste like what does it taste like it tastes like a little rancid but like pretty good oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm going berserk this way go crazy yeah that's that's all winners go berserk all winners go berserk yeah yeah yeah okay let's think about this i think you can go rock in front of you on the left yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this way okay yeah oh yeah oh yeah she's balling she's gaming she's rock climbing
i eat my trail makes nice and i go for my friends who are no longer here wait wait you should yeah you'll never make it how y'all doing hi i can't tell if y'all are real anymore i saw are you afraid of ghosts no good look me right in the eye then okay boo taking my stick oh my god taking my stick
Now you can go.
Are you afraid of imps and or mages?
Oh.
I'm afraid of everything.
Use those grippers.
Use those phalanges.
Use them.
Use them to your high content.
Use your grippers.
You're so close.
This is the easy part.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, maybe.
Grip away.
Where do you go from here?
Keep gripping that grip.
If you need more grip, you can use your toes.
If you need to grip, if you're done with gripping, you can also grapple.
Grip and grappling is also really yeah yeah Love that one specifically Some people Oh yeah that way that way yeah yeah Oh that's the good stuff Oh yeah Nothing could possibly go wrong Oh oh she pooted Oh no Okay I'm out of it It won't get me it won't get me Yeah I just had some of that That's not good Get to every time.
No, no, it's fine.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Grippy is Maximus.
They tell me I need to grip.
And all of my friends just ripped.
And I am so sad.
I am going to eat these thick mints.
And I'm going to get real thickness in my booty like the mint.
Take her BBL for myself.
What?
What, huh?
Nothing.
you're gonna take what nothing i didn't say nothing i give permission i said i'm gonna take her bbf put it in myself and then i'm gonna have the biggest butt that you have ever felt bigger than nymphs yeah yeah watch out jim girl you can't have it in the front and the back that's not fair how do you have it in the front and the back that's just too much you gotta share some with the They call that the double miler.
The double miler.
All right.
This is, now this, I'm going to get up there.
That's what I'm going to do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, if you had your BBL now, you could have used it to bounce up there, but...
Sorry, I don't know.
You're not having it yet.
I feel close to the end.
Wait, do you guys smell that burning wood of the campfire?
Because I do.
I do.
Look at the air!
I smell the mellows from here.
And what do I see?
Not a campfire in sight.
No, no, just keep going.
It's because you're hallucinating right now.
I see it!
What?
Where?
Up!
Just keep going!
Oh Through the fog and through the cold.
True the light little to the right.
Yeah a little to the right.
Yeah that way Yeah, I see it.
I see it.
Yeah Just I won't let you go.
Oh, yeah, there you go.
Yeah, yeah, I see Oh my god, we're actually we're actually gonna make it With the rain through the fog through the death of my my closest friend.
Friendship will still prevail.
Your friendship always prevails.
Wait, wait, wait!
Turn around, turn around!
Wait, it's that way!
I go.
Oh, yeah, you can go this way.
Sorry.
Okay, I got excited.
I was like, is it right there?
It's right there!
I gotta put it!
I gotta get it!
Yeah.
Meow.
Meow to the top.
Meow to the top, bunny.
Meow.
Thank you.
She did it.
You did it.
I need to do a little dance.
Okay, yeah.
Get that dance.
Oh yeah.
Victory dance.
Okay, friends.
Please bring my friends back.
Oh, statue.
We're coming home.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
We exploded.
Yeah.
You did it.
Hey, Monty!
Yay!
Group hug, group hug, group hug, group hug!
Yeah!
Perfect.
Oh, yeah!
Good job, climbers.
That was so beautiful, Monty Bigel.
I've never been more.
I've never felt so impressed in my life.
I know.
Thank you.
I like a proud father.
She's just crazy.
Mesa.
She's our hero.
Whoa.
Now we are back as well.
A quadro.
What do they call a team of four?
A pedro.
A quadro.
Pedro, Pedro, Pedro, Pedro.
Pedro, Pedro.
Guys, it's the Mesa biome and if anyone knows anyone better than Mesa, what?
I'm an expert at the Mesa, that's all I have to say.
This one, it can't be difficult.
What?
It's just a A bunch of rocks.
What is that?
Oh.
A bomb!
Oh!
Oh my boy!
My leg!
Is everybody all right?
I had a great view in all this way.
That
was like the best timing.
That was like the best timing.
It was so good.
Oh, there's a tornado!
Oh, what the heck?
What the hellie?
What the hellie, aren't they?
What the hellipa?
Where is everybody?
Where are you?
I died.
What?
I'm kind of in a crevice right now.
Oh no.
I slipped.
But I'm okay.
You're in a crevice.
I'll find you.
Yeah.
I'll piggyback you the whole way.
till i die anyway um oh i fell down oh hello you're here too oh behind you guys behind you guys oh look oh i'm gonna die before you see me oh my god oh my god there there oh no no guys what did i say what an expert mesa yep i take your stuff i told you yeah get the stuff get the stuff get the page oh yeah i do have a lot of good stuff in the backpack yeah Okay,
I was so close.
But her bones are my arms.
Wait, the bones are there still?
That's so freaky.
The bones in my arms.
Oh, wow.
It's so cute.
To where's, do we go now?
Um, let's just go forward, I guess.
Hey, Sean's good to me, man.
Whatever you say.
Yeah.
I don't think there's much we can do.
Except just walk.
Oh, and climb.
We're going for a hike.
Oh.
That bagel, go.
Yeah, go!
Go!
You climb with the bagel once and the bagel climbs once, but you teach a bagel to climb and it climbs forever.
That was so poetic.
Ouch!
Oh!
The ground is fire!
The ground is... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Oh!
They're flaying me!
Oh, oh, I'm...
Oh, oh, guys.
Don't, don't, don't, are you up there?
Where are you?
No, we're fine.
Oh, I see you.
I'm on the ground.
Yeah, hello, hello.
My vision's blurry.
Oh, God.
No, it's, it's not, it's not, we just gotta find a watering hole.
Oh, my gosh, it was fake!
I actually had a hallucination of a...
Oh, no!
I'm hallucinating.
I'm hallucinating water holes.
and suitcases.
Oh, God.
And tornadoes.
Oh.
Wait.
Wait, I think the tornado was real.
If the tornado is coming close to me, does that mean it's coming close to me?
If the tornado is coming close to me.
Oh, it's coming.
Oh.
Oh, no.
I wanted to suck me up.
Oh, God.
Oh, my.
Well, I'm experiencing that right now, and I got stuck to a cactus, and I can't move.
And I'm on fire.
What?
Wait, where?
Oh, no.
Oh, it's coming back.
I gotta go.
Oh, no.
The ground is hot.
The ground.
Run, Miss Big.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna get sucked.
Okay.
It's pretty fun to get sucked, but, you know, I don't recommend it.
No.
I scared.
Please.
It's going.
Oh, it's the end.
It's the end.
Oh, it's so hot.
I'm sucked.
I just double shook.
This is kind of like the rapture.
What in God's name are these sounds that I'm hearing?
I don't even know what direction is up anymore.
I can't give up.
There's a watering hole waiting for me.
I think I've got raptured.
I'm sure the cactus has water.
Yeah, the cactus has water!
Yeah, there you go!
Wait, my life bar is getting like crazy long.
How is this possible?
I know you have yellow, orange, red, black, green.
I've got the rainbow.
Yeah.
color of the rainbow do okay goodbye hello and she's dead all right oh no oh it's just you to carry it's you to carry i tell you don't be careful don't get out what direction do i go uh-huh up right of course don't go yeah not that way go go turn around yeah that way yeah that's the way oh okay okay i'll listen i've never died once in my life i've never Oh,
be careful, be careful though.
You seem to have gotten pricked there just a bit.
You okay?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I did this at Summer Camp.
That suitcase is probably not real, but you could check it out.
That one?
Yeah.
I'm gonna burn the death.
It ain't worth it.
I don't know.
But what if it's real?
Wait, there's so many of them.
You should just try opening it.
Yeah, just go.
Just go sniff it.
I can smell.
That one's real sure i could smell it it smells like yeah yeah go to it go to it yeah yeah that one's real for sure oh god oh no oh god don't worry your body is this oh no oh yeah now oh in there oh my toes nice did anyone see that corpse to the left over there just me i did see that yeah there's a boat pile of bones whose body was that in Uh-oh,
I have no idea.
Yes.
Misty.
Probably not one of us, probably someone else who's been here before.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, there's another one.
There's a beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Turn around, turn around.
Right there.
In the hole.
Oh, in the hole.
Holy shit, holy shit, holy shit, holy shit.
Oh my god.
I did not know that happened.
Me neither.
Oh.
We didn't lead you astray.
It was a fluke.
That was horrifying.
That was pretty freaky.
I did not like that.
The worm wanted to eat my toes.
They wanted your little toesies.
Please not my toes, princess.
They're pretty cute.
I don't blame them.
Oh, thanks.
Yeah, I got cute toes, man.
I got a pedicure, you know.
Is this like the deadliest biome that's in the world?
there is in this game.
This seems bad, yeah.
Fucking tornadoes, a worm in the floor.
I'm not gonna lie, I misjudged it.
After the hellscape that was the last bomb, I was like, nothing can be worse.
This is worse.
This is, yeah.
Yeah, this is even worse, I think, than the final level.
What?
And I have to do this without dying?
Yep.
That was the most innocent little Yep.
I hear, I think I hear the tornado.
Don't say such a thing.
There's no, there's, there's no such thing.
There's a suitcase below you.
It's real.
Wait, can you just keep going down?
What have you going down?
Oh, you have a bandage.
I would use that.
That's okay.
Yeah, I'm just gonna put that on real quick.
Don't mind me.
Oh, yes.
Oh, listen.
I'm a professional...
Everything I've ever done.
Professional.
What if there's like a...
What if there's an underground passageway?
Sunscreen!
Why you... Why you...
What?
Say it to my face.
You're like convulsing on the suitcase.
It's because I need sunburn.
It's part of the process, guys.
Come on.
It's part of the process.
I hear something coming.
I'm kind of scared.
But it's night time.
You don't need it now.
Ooh.
Where the answer is going horribly wrong if I use this?
Just use it.
Frick it.
It won't, yeah.
Use it.
Use it, point it upwards, and just, yeah.
Yeah, let it rip.
Let it rip.
I would position it so you make sure it's moving upwards.
Be careful.
Yeah, um...
Alright, um...
Yeah, hold on.
I think I need a better vantage point.
I think I'm gonna launch myself into a bunch of rocks and just die on site.
you grab the rocks it's genius wait you're right okay hold on right right over here perhaps perhaps i think maybe does this seem it is night time now by the way i feel like uh-huh okay i think you could just keep going you think why not i guess so i mean it is night time yeah i feel like maybe maybe we save the can honestly if you just keep going And don't think about it too much.
You'll get there.
Don't overthink.
Yeah.
To heck with the tornadoes.
The more you overthink, the more your brain will get big and you'll get weighted down.
You don't want to do that.
Look, you're already almost there.
I can see the top.
Yeah.
Bye-bye.
It's not too far up.
Yeah, yeah.
Wow, that is very far up.
No.
No, it's not.
Maybe a little to your right.
It's fine, don't worry about it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Just keep flopping.
Yeah, keep rubbing your body.
Oh, okay.
Um, hey, listen, hey.
Hey, listen, maybe, maybe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now you're thinking.
I'm thinking real big brain.
Yeah.
Camilla, do you have one of these in the circus?
Yep.
Do you have any tips?
Yeah, so you want to place it down?
the complete opposite direction so i want you to turn a little right with your head no right more right your other right your other right right right there yes right there and just look launch go crazy with it yeah you gotta light it first i don't think okay i think this is the best idea imaginable can we get in there how do i get it oh oh good oh god I don't think I did.
Ah, princess, I might have made a short miscalculation.
That worked exactly how I wanted it.
I imagine like, you know, in the cartoons, you have like a face full of ash.
It's just like...
Yeah, a face full of ash.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Hey, I've had a lot of that this whole gameplay.
My face full of ash.
don't worry about it oh oh oh oh i'm worrying oh yeah go from there go from that little platform yeah yeah yeah you know you could probably eat the sunscreen really yeah yeah yeah exactly oh the sun's coming what do i think i'm hallucinating what are you saying oh i don't know my vision got my fov it got big oh big fov oh no i'm putting this on put this Sit on!
Oh!
Get in it!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice and, nice and, uh, sunscreened up.
Yeah.
She's slippery.
Nice and slippery.
I'm...
Oh, it makes an oopy goopy noise when I climb now.
That's...
Oh, ew!
I really like this.
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on.
I just need to...
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You need a little snack.
I think it's time for sunscreen.
Left, left, left, left, left.
Yeah, left, left, left.
Yeah.
Oh, so close, so close.
Maybe go over there, that little ledge on the left right there, you see?
Like, there's, like, that little...
Yeah.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go, yeah.
Oh, no, it's a daisy.
Oh, no, I made it.
You made it, you made it.
Everything's fine, no, don't worry.
Test the sunscreen.
There you go, nice.
Is that an apple on there?
It's a cactus fruit.
Be careful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't be alarmed by the tornado getting closer and closer to you.
It's not even that close.
No, no, please.
I got tornadoed once already.
I don't need it again.
They sent me launching into a rock.
I got lucky I didn't get marked.
Oh, marked.
Okay.
Everything's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Yep.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Okay.
Do not me mark me.
Ooh, it's warm.
Oh, it's warm, Ow.
No, no, no, it's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Oh, okay!
Shift!
Oh, oh!
You're fine.
Okay, okay, I have an idea.
Things are green, yes.
Go up and there's a little ledge to the left.
A little tiny little ledge to the left.
Oh I'm seeing it.
Yeah, right there.
Get your stamina back, get your stamina, and then go all the way to the right ledge.
To the right?
Oh, hey, listen, this is fine.
Oh, yeah, that's...
That's fine.
Oh, wow, it actually worked.
There you go.
She's gaming.
Okay, Mimi, I don't want you to look up too far.
Just don't look up too far.
Just keep going.
Just keep trucking along at your own little Mimi pace.
Like, we're very proud of you.
Today, not tomorrow.
That's tomorrow Mimi's problem.
Today, Mimi is doing what she's got to do.
And he's doing her dardest.
I'm going to do something I might regret.
Oh, you made it.
Yeah, nice catch.
Nice catch.
It's fine.
Don't worry.
Very great catch.
Yes, yes.
Oh, beautiful.
Steady.
That's my purple.
So purple.
Yes.
Oh, thank you so much.
So purple and bald.
Purple's a great color.
If you guys want me to kill myself so you can restart, just let me know.
Purple and bald.
She's got it all.
Well, uh, involved?
Yeah.
You got a little hat.
Look at your dome.
Oh, man.
Oh no.
New song remix?
Hmm.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Donate me.
Oh, there's a lot of bombs.
Look at her dome.
Yes, she's got it all.
She's in the mesa.
She's got the peso.
Oh.
Wait, where's my sunscreen?
I used it.
Oh, we're cooked.
Oh, we're cooking.
Please don't slip up, we...
We got the sun clean.
Wonder skin.
Wait,
there's scorpions in here too?
This is messed up.
Mint laughing into the...
The fucking...
What is that?
A kazoo?
Oh my gosh, that was so funny.
That was too good.
This place wants me dead, it wants me dead, and it did.
She pleased.
I'm only Well guess what you're in a ditch and you're not dead So keep going You got this Keep going We believe in you We're in a ditch You're doing so splendid Right behind you Right behind you Oh wait You're in a ditch But you ain't no bitch Yeah yeah yeah yeah Hey Her name is Mimi She's in the manta She's always climbing She is so cute He's got the sunscreen It makes her slip hurry.
She's Mimi.
Yeah How are you sis?
What was that?
Wait for it.
I'm waiting.
Is it is it going upwards?
Oh, it goes upwards What the fuck?
Oh shit.
I'm burning Do you have any items in your backpack?
Oh, yeah, you do.
Oh, maybe what do I have?
You have a bandages and a sports string.
Sports string.
Oh my god.
I forgot I took this off of Camilla earlier.
Hold on.
Oh, my dead body.
My little dead body.
Give to me, use it.
Yeah.
Nice.
And the bandages will help too.
Yeah.
See, it all ties together.
Like it all makes sense.
I died so that she could have my backpack and we would be here.
And then we're all here.
Everything happens for a reason, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, you're here.
This was funny that way.
It's not worth it.
It's fine.
Oh, I can make it.
Oh, I'm so...
Oh, Jesus.
Oh, that was close.
Right, fine.
Anyways, I'll go this way.
Don't worry about it.
You were just red eagle just convulsing on that rock.
That was crazy.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it, princesses.
There was a suitcase over there if you wanted to try for it.
It was before.
I love it.
English and it's all right okay we don't look back yeah we're going forward this is this is how yeah don't look back on the past everybody guys look at the discord chat look at this discord chat
what happened okay hold on what happened i need to show this guy i need to show him
post That's freaking hilarious Oh, oh no I'm crying We retweet you guys Yeah, I already that was an instant retweet though Oh guys guys, we can't get distracted Mimi is...
Oh, uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh, Mimi is stuck.
Oh, you guys, she got some thorns in her hand.
Wait, watch out for the bomb.
Oh, that's...
Oh, so true.
So true.
The way you said that's so true.
What do I...
Boom.
Right?
Right, anyways.
The flip explode.
I'll go this way now.
I can't see she...
I'm blind as bad.
Okay.
Oh, no, you're good.
You're good, yeah.
Is this...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do I go this way, you think?
I'm surprised the fog hasn't claimed me yet.
I won't lie to you.
Yeah, me too.
I feel good in front of it all.
That's not very encouraging, but you meant it.
Oh, sorry.
No, it's okay.
Thank you.
Don't worry about it.
This has to be the right way.
I mean...
You're getting a little foggy over this side.
I think you're going a little too far to the fog.
fog no no fog claims oh oh oh oh oh oh you're okay you're okay check in the suitcase yeah just just a little neck it's just a little neck you know oh i need so bad a little paper cut what's wrong with a little paper cut there's another bomb oh yeah what is that thing i don't know oh what what yeah oh yeah that helped so much i can't get off of it get off baby it's not working okay oh she has like she has like little things in her arm and everything i feel so bad listen everyone i want you to know i fucking love you guys i'm sorry no let's go no no
I mean, you know, I was in the middle of writing a rap about this.
Oh, no.
Give her a beat, give her a beat.
Give me a beat while I die.
I got four lines.
Ready?
Yeah.
Hey.
She's in a maze.
Sunscreen on her face.
She's scared and in a ditch.
But no, she ain't a bitch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey.
Good shit, everybody.
What are the hearts, man?
But all things considered, that could have been so much worse.
Honestly, you really, you put up a good fight.
You did, you did, yeah.
Thanks.
Hey, listen, that's the best I've ever done.
And you know what?
You did wonderful.
I pat you on your little head.
Oh, thank you.
Good job.
I mean, sorry I didn't finish for five.
For all of our struggles, honestly, I feel we've done very well today.
It's so true.
you know it's it's not about the the heights we've climbed but rather the the friends we made on the way you know friendship the bbls we popped the bbls that we've acquired yeah yeah i'll never what do i look like now i'll never be the same all the shrooms we consumed honey it's okay everybody sometimes people just have concave butts and that's okay like me it's okay yeah look at mine After all that,
mine's concave now.
Wait, let me see.
Let me see.
I'm still self-conscious.
Can I see your butt?
Can I feel the concaveness?
Yeah, I feel it.
Okay.
Really get in there, too.
It's pretty deep.
Okay.
Let me try to.
Dang.
Ow!
Too deep.
Oh, sorry.
It's like a cavern in there.
It just felt like I was kept going.
Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
Let me just, uh, let me echo.
Nuddy-puddy cave over here.
Damn.
Oh my goodness.
It really is big.
Yeah.
wow guys i think we did a great great job today i think so too yeah you know we don't need to reach the top we've reached peak peak we reached the peak period exactly yeah there was definitely no scuff nothing none of that what is stuff about this setup yeah don't say yeah i've had a I only remember what I mean.
Perfetus.
I'm fetus.
Yeah, oh yeah.
No, this was delightful.
Yeah!
It was, it was.
I had a lot of fun.
Yeah!
Yeah, me too.
Let's play games together again sometime.
Yeah.
Sure.
Anytime.
We touch them amazingly quick.
We just...
Oh, yes.
I hope to see you triple BBL next time.
Oh, don't you know it.
Glintop will be hit.
Mint's gonna come back and she's just gonna be fully like, like, like puffed up like a fucking marshmallow boy, like a pills boy.
Yeah.
Everything is gonna be injected.
I'll never, I'll never die from fall damage again.
Yeah.
We'll just bounce.
We'll constantly bounce.
Yeah, you can just, I'll just lay down and you guys can jump on my body.
Oh, yes, he'll be our fall if we need it.
It won't hurt.
We won't break any more bones or anything.
Oh, my god.
That's horrible.
I'm just visiting that.
It's so horrible.
I died a second time for that.
I better get out of here before I actually die.
Please don't die.
Don't die.
Oh, I won't.
I won't.
I love you, sweet fairy.
Instead, I explode.
Oh, no.
Oh, she's actually gone.
Oh, no, my dear.
Hold on.
There she goes.
Okay, guys.
Okay.
That was our next BBL session.
Till our next BBL session.
I'll never forget you.
Oh, my God.
Oh, love you.
Kiss you, kiss you.
Oh.
Yay.
What's...
Oh, she's so fast!
What?
Oh my god!
I need a new... I need a new...
uh, mouse, apparently.
Ah!
Good.
Oh.
What happened?
How did she do that?
How was she so talented?
Okay, I leave.
Ta-da!
I hope you guys had fun.
With Peek.
Wow.
Guys, I think we need Limeu.
Guys.
Guys, we're nothing without Limeu.
It was so fun, though.
Yeah, I'm so much fun with everybody.
Oh, Limeu hard carry.
Limeu's our pro.
But the Mesa!
The Mesa was too difficult.
Why does it have cactus at heat?
It has tornado, it has scorpion, it has...
Everything!
There was dynamite, yeah!
It had so many!
So many dangers!
Fake Need, thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, and the big bug in the pit!
It's crazy!
I feel like that's a final level.
with the amount of hazards or...
I guess you get kind of like...
Uh...
What's the word?
A break when it turns night.
But...
Like, what the heck?
What the heck?
Good morning, meepto.
Good morning, glam jamming!
We're jamming, jamming, jamming.
Welcome back, thank you.
And mirages!
I got bamboozled.
I think...
I've always thought that if I were in the desert and dehydrated with nothing around, I thought I would be stronger when I would never hallucinate.
Clearly not.
Clearly, I'm weak.
And I fell for it.
I did.
That one was crazy.
That was a crazy...
map.
But I'm glad that we got to see the new one, at least.
So, yeah.
You would see Osalaw.
Maybe, though.
I thought the volcano was the most dangerous biome.
Honestly, compared to this, it feels like the volcano didn't have enough.
Like, all it is, I mean, of course, it's a difficult climb, but, like, it feels like they...
It doesn't have enough hazards.
Maybe they added some stuff, though.
Okay.
There's a golden idol if you bring...
If bing bong is in there.
In the volcano?
You hear the meow echoing off the cannonballs.
Man.
I've played a lot and the mesa is very long, but the volcano is definitely harder.
It was...
It's the shore, the jungle.
either the mesa or the cold and then the final one, right?
It's just the four?
I can't remember what the other one was.
There we go, thank you!
Not sure if you're keeping up with Meow Tower, Music Box Dailies, but I think you would like this one.
I haven't been keeping up with the Dailies, but I'll check it out.
I'll check it, thank you.
Volcano has two stages.
That's right!
That's right.
There's the outside and then the inside.
Yeah, the volcano and then the kiln.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I forgot about that.
I forgot about that.
Crazy!
But I really appreciate you guys watching.
I didn't...
I...
Let me put everybody's...
I couldn't find like everybody's YouTube to tag them in.
So let me put their Twitters at least.
so that Mimi so that you can find them all if you were like I don't know this person because everybody is very funny very sweet Mouni Bagel I got to meet Mimi and Mouni at Of Kai and they were so sweet they were so nice and we might be doing some more stuff the future together so wait oh my gosh i don't know how the youtube okay um me me or i will do money a minute a me me since that's the order i have okay you paste you copy paste and i've said before but money is like maybe the prettiest person i've ever met
She's so cute.
Alright, updated the description.
I haven't put out my schedule yet for this week, but I will put it out after the stream.
And, yeah.
This means you're pretty too since you're Moni.
No!
I'm sending the Supa after caching in my first checkbox.
of my new job!
Goffal!
Thank you for all of my time on streaming.
If you miss it, it's my last one.
Poor, it says Goffal!
No, don't send me that.
You should get something delicious for yourself instead.
No!
Congrats, though.
And I have merch.
Until the end of this month.
October 2025 in case you're watching it a different a different time I have merch ending this month for my birthday
that thanks for the fun streak lab thank you thank you thank you I had so much fun I was so sad that we had to push it back but I'm I'm really glad we were able to do it.
Use your recommendation and got the partner Q-Pot!
Gelato Peek!
Stuff for her birthday and she seemed to like it all.
Setsukami-ki!
Oh!
Nice!
I love Gelato Peek and Q-Pot.
Thanks, sir.
You followed my...
You thought my advice was good?
You actually listen to me?
You listen to me?
You...
Followed my advice and then it worked up.
You were...
Am I an influencer?
Ah, thank you.
I don't know why I'm thanking you.
But...
Well, I guess thank you for you, sir, taking my advice.
For trusting me.
Thank you for trusting me.
For non-Twitter folks, EU merch shipping is better now.
Yeah.
It is.
Steiner apparently was like, I'm gonna have it all shipped to my house, and I'll ship it from my house.
I think we made some good music.
I think we made some good memories.
I think we're a good team.
Even if we don't...
We're not a good team in that we win.
But we win in friendship.
Okay!
I'm gonna go now.
Thank you guys so, so much for hanging out with me again.
Um...
And I will see you when I see you next.
And...
Yeah!
Watabito!
Oh, to maintain.
Out your way, though.
Okay, I'm just going to take my leave now.
I'm just, I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll, I can't see you out, but I'll, you know, I'm just, I'll just, I'll just go this way.
Okay, and you're going that way, and I'm going this way, and you're going that way, and I'm going this way, so it won't be awkward, you know, when I, when I go this way, and you go that, I go this way, you go that way, we're not going to run into each other or anything,
you know, so.
Digital Canary, welcome back!
Yeah, I'll see you guys.
I go this way.
You go that way.
Okay?
Wait, I'm going that way too.
No, no!
The only my maid cafe is this way.
There's no one else.
Go eyes with me, though.
No!
Avoid the tornado.
Okay, I'm going this way.
You guys are going that way.
No, no, you're not following me.
No, no.
I'm going this way.
Okay.
All right.
I followed your advice about Hawk to a Coin and I'm bankruptcy.
Please advise.
Actually, that was very...
Ooh.
Advised.
Oh, wow.
Would you look at the time?
It's time for me to go this way.
Okay.
Bye.
Bye!